Halloback.
Das ist jemand da?
Was?
Aber es wird auch pausen wieder.
Niemand hier.
Lol, alter Lahn, lol.
So, ähm, ich hab heute Morgen und Vormittag noch ein bisschen hier dran herum gebastelt.
Von unserem Meme Overlay Stream Tool.
Und ich hab jetzt auf GitHub die erste Testversion mal rauf gepusht vorhin vor 45 Minuten.
Das heißt, wer mal ausprobieren will, kann mal ausprobieren.
Ich hab aber noch ein paar neue Sachen eingebaut, ich zeig euch das gleich.
Und wir müssen das Webinterface heute mal ein bisschen hübscher machen.
Das sieht immer noch ziemlich räudig aus.
Das machen wir jetzt noch.
Wir machen so ein bisschen Fine-Tuning, machen wir jetzt noch mal.
Aber man kann es schon benutzen, das funktioniert.
Also sprich, wer das mal ausprobieren will, der kann sich das hier runterladen auf GitHub.
Ich kann das gleich mal zeigen.
Das ist selbstverständlich natürlich auch alles, alles, ne, mit Bitcoin Miner, mit Keylogger ist alles drin.
Leider funktioniert das nicht, weil ich meine, das ist open source auf GitHub.
Ähm, das ist im Varo.
Das sind die Webemodes, das muss sein.
So, ähm, ich zeig euch mal was.
Ich hab was Neues eingebaut.
Und zwar, jetzt mal aus, man kann jetzt, man kann jetzt Text-to-Speech, Text-to-Speech, warte mal, ist die Lautstärke ein?
Okay, ja, ne.
Ähm, man kann jetzt Text-to-Speech-Emodes verwenden.
Aber erstmal zeig ich euch, wie man das Ganze benutzt.
Und vorher poste ich das mal auf Twitter.
Das wird alles.
So.
So, und danach mit 28 Grad Programmier-Stream.
Nein, bei mir ist keine 28 Grad. Bei mir ist hier, ich würd mal sagen, was ist, bei mir, warte mal, ich komm mal 25 Grad.
25 Grad ist hier drin und ich kann im Zweifelsfall immer noch die Klimaanlage anmachen.
So, ähm, ja, ich zeig euch gleich, was das Ding kann.
Ähm, ich muss erstmal kurz Twitter, Twitter posten.
So, jetzt gepostet.
Ach, was, den Baro, das könnt ich machen, ich könnt wirklich die Custom-Wall verwenden.
Also, ich zeig euch das mal, ich hab das hier, also, was soll ich zuerst zeigen, wie man's verwenden kann?
Ich mein, das ist ziemlich simpel, äh, runterladen und ausführen, das ist jetzt nicht so schwierig.
Oder soll ich euch mal das neue Text-to-Speech-Feature zeigen?
Ich zeig euch erstmal das neue Text-to-Speech-Feature, beste.
Also, man kann jetzt, ich hab das ganze erweitert, man kann jetzt in seinen Meme-Ordner, kann man Text-Files legen,
ähm, dem Ding auch einen Shortcut geben, sogar übers Web-Interface ausführen und dann liest das vor.
Das ist so richtig, richtig dumm, ja?
Wir brauchen nur irgendeine richtig schöne, Leute, ich brauch mal eine richtig schöne sinnlose Copypasta,
die wir jetzt hier verwenden können.
Sag mal, ich guck mal, ich hab ja ein extra Meme und sinnlose Copypasta Text-File, ich guck da mal rein.
Also bisher, ne, kennt ihr ja, bisher kann man hier nur in Anführungsstrichen,
kann man ja nur Bildchen mit Shortcuts overlayen lassen, ja?
Sonst, äh, sonst nix.
Aber jetzt, ganz neu, kann man auch Text-to-Speech machen.
Cray-Gas, Text-to-Speech, ähm, Oceanman, genau, oh, das ist ein bisschen lang, das ist ein bisschen lang.
Aber wir probieren das mal, wir probieren das mal.
Genau, die Oceanman-Copypasta nehmen wir jetzt mal.
Also, von der Idee her ist das so, ich mach mal kurz aus, eine ist schon aus, ähm, man kann jetzt hier einen Text-File anlegen.
Ich hoffe, das Ding kommt mit den ganzen, äh, mit den ganzen Emojis klar in das Text-File.
Jetzt kann man hier zum Beispiel sagen, wenn man das jetzt auf, auf 1 legen will, sagt man jetzt hier, was weiß ich, 1, plupp, TXT,
kopiert den Text dann da rein, oh, das wird grausam.
So, speichert das, und wenn ich jetzt Steuerung 1 drücke, ich muss ja erst mal starten,
und wenn ich jetzt Steuerung 1 drücke, die ist davor, ich hoffe, das ist jetzt nicht zu laut.
Warum geht das nicht?
Das geht nicht.
Ha, das ist kaputt, warum ist das kaputt?
Warte mal, ach, ach, Moment, das ist der falsche, das ist der falsche Ordner.
Moment.
Leute, ich glaub, ich glaub, das ist der falsche Ordner.
Wartet mal.
Ich glaub, das ist der falsche Ordner, das backt hier irgendwie rum, da hat er nicht erkannt, dass es da ist.
Jaja, ähm, so.
Okay, jetzt geht's bestimmt.
Auch nicht? Warum nicht? The fuck?
Warum geht das nicht? Habe ich das?
Ach, TXT, TXT, okay, weil, weil Windows.
Jaja, verstehe.
Äh, äh, Moment, irgendwie ist das, ist das ganz schön broken gerade.
Moment, warum ist das doppelt TXT?
Was ist das, was ist das für ein Scheiß?
Rename.
TXT, TXT.
Oh Gott, Windows.
Alter.
Windows 0 in 2K18.
So, mal mach so.
Schieben wir's rein, weil ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen das Windows jetzt hier nicht Dateiänderungen anzeigt.
Auch gut.
Ah, Dateiänderungen sind ausgeblendet, stimmt.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das überhaupt einblenden muss.
Ich hab das seit Ewigkeiten schon bei mir eingeblendet.
Ah, hier, da, guck mal.
Krass.
Windows, Alter.
So.
Nur geht's aber hoffentlich.
Nee, nur geht's immer noch, weil jetzt muss ich ja noch einstellen, dass er den Scheiß kopieren soll.
So.
Das braucht ihr natürlich nicht, ne?
Ihr macht ja keine Builds und kopiert danach irgendwelche Dinger rum.
So, jetzt aber.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was funktioniert.
Bisschen lang, vielleicht?
Gut, also, er funktioniert.
So, übrigens, man kann auch abbrechen, ne?
Also, wenn du jetzt vorliest.
Ich kann auch abbrechen.
Beziehungsweise, ich kann nicht abbrechen, ich kann neu starten.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch einen Abbrechen-Knopf reinmachen.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Ja, wir sollten noch einen Abbrechen-Knopf reinmachen.
Wir sollten noch einen Stopfknopf einbauen, glaube ich.
Das wäre nicht verkehrt.
So.
Gut, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal das Web-Interface.
Was immer noch genauso räudig aussieht, wie das letzte Mal.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen was Kürzeres.
Weil, wenn ich das jetzt jedes Mal abspiele, ist es viel zu lang.
Ich brauche kürzere Copypasta.
Warte mal, ich guck mal in meinen.
Wo habe ich denn hier mein Copypasta-Text-Datei?
Nehmen wir echt ein Lucio-Quote, das geht auch.
Mal gucken, wie ihr das vorliest.
Man kann übrigens auch die Stimme ändern.
Man kann auch die Stimme ändern.
Also standardmäßig nimmt man jetzt einfach die default-Stimme,
die zur jeweiligen Sprache und zur jeweiligen Region passt.
Aber man kann auch die Stimme auswählen.
Ich habe da nichts eingebaut, dass man die Stimme auswählen kann.
Man kann die prinzipiell auswählen, aber ich habe noch kein Menü,
wo man es auswählen kann.
Schreibe ich mir auch mal auf.
Gibt es auch fiepsige Anime-Stimme, wenn du eine installiert hast.
Es gibt alle Stimmen, die installiert sind.
Also sprich alle Stimmen, die man bei Windows 10 installieren kann.
Und wenn es da die krasse Weep-Anime-Stimme gibt,
dann kannst du sie auch einstellen.
Sobald ich ein Menü eingebaut habe.
Jetzt zeige ich euch mal das neue Webinterface.
Also was ist neu? Das Webinterface hat bloß zwei coole neue Sachen.
Ich bin halt die ganze Ecke schneller am basteln,
als wenn ich am streamen bin.
Als offline.
Also als erstes kann man jetzt mal das Webinterface starten
und stoppen über das Tray-Icon.
Und wir müssen jetzt mal das, wie stellt man das ein?
Ich habe seit Windows 10 immer riesige Probleme,
Windows-Settings zu finden.
Wo kann ich denn hier einstellen?
Ah ja, das da.
Ich will einstellen, dass das Icon immer angezeigt wird hier.
Und zack.
Also man kann jetzt erst mal start stoppen vom Webinterface
über das Tray-Icon. Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
So, dann geht mal an den zweiten Rechner.
Nachdem ich jetzt keinen zweiten Rechner habe,
mache ich das am gleichen Rechner.
Und dann geht man hier auf seine IP.
Port 5001.
Und dann hat man hier sein ganzes Zeug drin geladen.
Und wenn man es anklickt, zeigt das an.
Aber das kennt ihr ja schon. Das ist nichts Neues.
Was jetzt neu ist, dass man eine Anzeige hat für Soundfiles.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier draufklick und es zeigt.
Also wie gesagt, es ist gedacht,
um es vom zweiten Rechner aus zu bedienen.
Oder vom Tablet oder vom Smartphone oder so.
Also sprich, das Schöne an Webinterfaces,
man kann das halt von überall bedienen.
Also sprich, wenn ihr jetzt,
ihr macht jetzt hier die IP von eurem Rechner.
Port 5000. Blablabla.
Dann könnt ihr vom Smartphone drauf gehen.
Dann hier antippen, was quasi beim Stream...
So im Prinzip so ein bisschen wie das VL Gato Stream Deck.
Habt ihr dann auf dem Smartphone.
Also sprich, ihr könnt auf dem Smartphone auf die Webseite klicken
und dann die einzelnen Bildchen anklicken.
Auf eurem Smartphone zeigt das an.
Also ich mach das jetzt hier nur exemplarisch auf meinem Rechner.
Also es ist nicht gedacht, das am gleichen Rechner zu machen.
Weil es ist ja irgendwie total bescheuert.
So sieht man ja nix.
So und was der jetzt kann...
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Das war ein ganz schöner Akt, bis das funktioniert hat.
Man kann jetzt hier sagen, okay, ich hab jetzt hier mal mein Zeug.
Plus ich kann Text-to-Speech-triggern.
Und ihr seht, das geht sogar automatisch wieder aus,
wenn die Wiedergabe weg ist.
Wisst ihr, was das für ein Akt war?
Bis das funktioniert hat.
Also ich kann jetzt so machen.
Irgendwas einblenden, ausblenden.
Und es ist multi...
Also sprich mit Background-Thread.
Das macht den Hintergrund.
Ich kann das immer weiter bedienen, obwohl das abspielt.
Plus, dass er den Status aktualisiert.
Also es ist nicht schlecht.
Poggers ist das.
Okay, vielleicht sollte man sich hier eine Kopie Pasta überlegen.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert's.
Und ich zeige euch noch mal was Geiles.
Man kann jetzt...
Also ich sitze jetzt ein bisschen doof, ne?
Wenn man jetzt in das...
Ich versuche euch das jetzt mal hier so zu zeigen.
Also stelle euch vor, das ist der zweite Rechner.
Übrigens, als nächstes bauen wir irgendwann noch ein,
dass man track-and-drop neue Memes im Webinterface machen kann,
weil das im Ordner ist ein bisschen nervig.
So, gehen wir mal hier rein.
So, und mal angenommen, ich mache jetzt so.
Ich lösche das hier.
Ich lösche das jetzt mal.
Zack, ist es weg.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Live-Update vom Frontend.
Krass, oder?
So, und jetzt schiebe ich es hier wieder rein.
Bam, da ist es wieder.
Inklusive Keymapping und allem, was dann weg ist.
Ups.
So, jetzt probieren wir mal aus,
wie das mit ein bisschen mehr Memes funktioniert.
Mal gucken, ob das mit dem Textfile,
mit Textfiles habe ich noch nicht probiert.
Doch, geht auch.
Und man sieht auch, wie schnell das ist.
Das ist echt nice.
So, jetzt...
Jetzt kopieren wir da mal ein bisschen mehr rein.
Kopieren wir mal den Krams hier alles rein.
Mal gucken, ob es crasht.
Das habe ich noch nie probiert,
mehrere Sachen rein zu kopieren.
So, wir löschen mal alles.
Ich habe noch nie probiert,
was es ist, wenn man mal alles löscht.
Ach, geht ja nicht.
Ha, geht ja nicht.
Weil er hat ja noch Bilder geladen.
Na gut, dann machen wir mal kurz aus.
Machen wir da an und kopieren hier mal
den ganzen Scheiß rein.
Start.
So, dann starten wir das Webinterface.
Das muss man immer einmal machen,
weil meistens will man vielleicht
das Webinterface gar nicht haben,
sonst haben wir hier alles drin.
Dann kann man hier jetzt...
Schön vor sich hin meme'n.
Was jetzt hier im Webinterface nicht schlecht wäre,
wenn das hier noch ein ordentliches Crit wäre.
Das gucke ich mir ab.
Es gibt nämlich ein Pullogequest,
da hat einer einen Crit gebaut,
weil ich habe im Webfrontend überhaupt keinen Plan von.
Mindplone Webfrontend.
Aber man sieht, dass es funktioniert
auch mit mehreren Sachen.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch ein
gescheites Crit hier machen,
damit das nicht so hässlich aussieht.
Das machen wir jetzt gleich noch.
So, wie gesagt, Text-to-Speech
habe ich euch auch schon gezeigt.
Ach ja, und das Beste ist,
was natürlich sehr praktisch ist,
also ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal, wie das ist,
wenn man sich das runter lädt von GitHub,
wie das dann aussieht.
Also angenommen, ihr wollt das jetzt verwenden.
Lässt sich bestimmt auch Bootstab...
Ja, wahrscheinlich können wir einfach Bootstab reinhauen
und es sieht immer noch ganz gut aus.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
So, also wenn man das jetzt verwenden will
und es wäre schön, wenn es ein paar Leute testen würden,
weil ich meine, es funktioniert bei mir am Rechner.
Es funktioniert bei mir auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Ich habe es dann auch nochmal
ein bisschen rumgetestet.
Ja, also funktioniert prinzipiell.
Aber wenn es mehr Leute ausprobieren würden
als der, der es gebastelt hat, wäre nicht verkehrt.
Also, das ist super einfach.
Es gibt keinen Installer, es gibt nichts.
Man lädt sich einfach hier die Exe oder das Zip runter,
wo halt dann wieder eine ausführbare Datei drin ist.
Und ja, ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal.
Also man lädt sich das runter.
Dann meckert irgendwann der Chrome rum,
dass es ein beschwaltetes Exe ist,
ein ganz furchtbar gefährliches Pfeil ist wahrscheinlich.
Was es halt nicht ist.
Aber es steht hier dann freilang,
50.000 Virenscanner drüber laufen zu lassen
oder das eben von Source zu kompilieren.
Jeder wie er will.
Also, ihr ladet euch die Exe runter.
Und dann, also, ich mache mal einen neuen Ordner.
Das ist, ich gehe jetzt mal von aus,
ich habe es noch nicht runtergeladen.
So, ihr ladet die Exe runter.
Und dann startet ihr es einfach. Fertig.
Dann meckert das Ding natürlich, weil
ich bin ja kein signierter Publisher.
Das ist jetzt neu unter Windows 10.
Das muss man einmal bestätigen.
Muss man sagen, ja, ich weiß, das ist nichts gefährliches.
Das muss man aber ja mittlerweile bei jedem Scheiß,
den man runterlädt unter Windows.
Das könnte ich höchstens umgehen,
wenn ich mir so ein Codesign,
ein Zertifikat oder so hole.
So, dann machen wir ein Run.
Und dann funktioniert es. Das war's.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Dann läuft es.
Exe runterladen, anklicken, starten.
Gut ist.
Das ist alles. Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Dann erstellt er einen Memesordner direkt neben der Exe.
Und da kann man dann seine Bilder reinschieben.
Zum Beispiel.
Also, wenn ihr ein Bild haben wollt, was an die...
Ich habe ja so eine kleine Ritmi geschrieben hier unten drunter.
Wenn man jetzt ein Bild haben will
und es auf Steuerung F binden will,
dann zieht man das rein.
Und dann hat man das hier auf dem Shortcut.
So, und man sieht das auch.
Dann kann man auch hier das Webinterface starten.
Da muss man einmal sagen, man erlaubt
Zugriff aufs Netzwerk.
Das ist halt auch bei Windows so.
Das muss man halt machen.
Man kann nicht auch nichts dran ändern.
So, und dann geht man eben mit dem zweiten Rechner
oder mit dem gleichen Rechner drauf.
Und dann hat man hier seinen...
Sein Remote, sein Webinterface.
Also, es ist super simpel.
Man muss eigentlich gar nichts machen,
außer das Ding runterladen, starten
und in den Memesordner Bilder reinziehen.
Fertig.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Also, das ist wirklich ziemlich einfach.
So.
Also, ne?
Da ist nichts Großartiges dabei.
Ist der Part-Hintergrund,
der im Hintergrund auf meinem Rechner
Bitcoin Miner schon drinne?
Also, es ist ein Bitcoin Miner drinne.
Es ist ein Ethereum- und Monero Miner drinne.
Ein Keylogger und natürlich auch
Memo-Zugriff.
Jebaited.
Ich kann jetzt leider nichts einplanen.
Hier.
Jebaited.
Alter, jebaited.
Wenn du der Sache nicht traust,
muss sich ja keiner installieren,
aber ich mein,
man kann sich den Source Code einfach angucken
und wird feststellen, da ist nichts drin.
Man kann sich den Source Code angucken,
man kann es auch selbst kompilieren.
Ja, und übrigens,
was ich jetzt gerade noch sagen wollte,
ihr habt gesehen,
das ist nur ein Exo-File.
Die komplette Anwendung hier,
ihr seht, wie viel Geschütz das ist,
ist eine Single-Executable.
Sieht es hier.
Release es.
Da mal groß machen.
Da ist ein Release-Knopf jetzt auf einmal.
Release es.
Dann kann man sich einfach hier runterladen,
und gut ist.
Alter, laden zu sehen,
weil ich komme jetzt auch immer aus.
Ja, ich bin mal recht unkreativ.
Wie gesagt,
ich habe auch so eine kleine Rhythmie
dabei geschrieben,
dass man weiß, was man machen muss.
Also es ist meiner Ansicht nach
wirklich simpel zu bedienen.
Man muss halt nur seine Bilder richtig nennen.
Man kann auch Memes oder Bilder,
man muss jetzt ja nicht
für irgendwelche doofen Meme-Bildchen verwenden.
Man kann im Prinzip alles damit anzeigen.
Man kann so normale Bilder anzeigen,
normale GIFs.
Aber wer will das schon, ne?
Einfach runterladen, starten,
Bilder reinziehen, fertig.
Also Bilder reinziehen reicht ja einmal.
So.
Ja, und das ist nur eine Echse,
und das war gar nicht so einfach,
denn man sieht ja hier,
das eigentliche Verzeichnis
hat ganz schön viele Files drinnen
neben der Echse.
Und wenn ich die lösche,
geht das nicht mehr.
Aber glücklicherweise
hab ich hier so ein...
so ein Ding gefunden,
was das alles mercht zusammen in eine Echse.
Das ist unglaublich praktisch.
Wann kommt die plattformübergreifende Version?
Ey, das ist,
nachdem da so viel Windows-spezifischer
Mist drinne ist, nie.
Nie.
Das funktioniert nicht woanders.
Allein schon die Windows Text-to-Speech-Engine
funktioniert ja nicht.
Ja.
Okay, ähm...
Genau, es kommt nämlich dann am Ende
eine Echse raus,
die man sich runterladen kann,
ausführen kann und gut ist.
Also es ist eine
sehr praktische Geschichte,
was es natürlich auch ziemlich einfach macht.
Runterladen, ausführen,
Bilder rein, troppen, gut ist.
Ja, ich wollte jetzt noch
ein bisschen das Web-Interface
hübsch machen.
Aber erst mal brauchen wir
noch ein bisschen mehr Bildchen.
Wir brauchen noch mehr Bildchen.
Das ist übrigens,
das wird übrigens nicht ins
Get-Committed-Nase,
das sag ich noch gleich dazu.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur zum Testen.
Ihr müsst da schon
eure eigenen Bildchen reinziehen.
Jetzt krieg ich noch irgendwelche
Copyright-Probleme.
Was ist das für ein File-Format?
Was ist denn das?
Ist das ein PNG?
Jifif.
Alter, was?
Was zum Teufel ist Jifif?
Aha, JPEG, okay.
Das heißt, die coolen Leute
nennen JPEG nicht JPEG
oder J-P-G oder J-P-E-G,
sondern Jifif.
Sehr interessant.
Jifif.
Hallo, Mr. Hard Toast.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch einstellen,
dass er das immer kopiert.
Äh, Jifif.
Kann man da nicht einfach
irgendwie was einstellen jetzt?
Wo ist das Problem?
Das ist ein Problem,
warum kann ich den Scheiß nicht selecten?
Oh, oh, das überfordert
Visual Studio jetzt,
für 20 Files was zu setzen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ähm, Sebaro, man muss keine Taste zuweisen.
Ja, irgendeiner hat
der Meinung, was zu erkennen, na dann.
Aber man kann sich
den Source Code hier angucken.
So, und jetzt.
Wow.
Ach so, es läuft schon.
Ja, okay, doppelt starten
kann man es natürlich nicht.
Oder, oder, ich habe
irgendwas doppelt kopiert,
kann das sein?
Jaja, die Textseitei ist doppelt.
Also, die Textseitei umbenennen.
Was ist denn hier noch frei?
F11 ist noch frei, oder?
Ja, dann, dann wird es jetzt F11.
F11 geht es.
7.
Funktioniert alles.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt
das Web-Interface
noch ein bisschen hübsch machen,
dass es nicht mehr so hässlich aussieht.
Also, ich zeige das mal,
wie das Web-Interface gerade aussieht.
Starten, reload, so, es sieht
halt nach nichts aus, das Web-Interface
nach gar nichts.
Es ist halt einfach nur,
einfach nur Bildchen da.
Oder halt, wenn es
in Text-to-Speech, wow.
Was geht denn da ab?
Das ist, glaube ich, das GIF,
das GIF, wie ja die coolen Leute
immer sagen.
Das GIF ist das hier,
was da so komisch rumspackt.
So.
Meine Fahrtangabe, ja, frag mich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe einfach auf Bild gedrückt,
das Ding.
Ach so, ne, das ist,
das ist, wenn du debuggen willst.
Also, das, natürlich, findest du,
findest du für die Release-Version
keine Debug-Symbole
und vor allem schon nicht
bei mir auf dem Desktop.
Also, ich weiß nicht,
wie man das da rauskriegt.
Müssen wir wahrscheinlich
irgendwie da nochmal
etwas entfernen danach, oder so.
Aber, ich meine,
man braucht ja eigentlich
auch keine Debug-Symbols,
wenn man es einfach nur verwendet.
Ich habe noch nie dort Netzzeug
auf GitHub hochgeladen,
und es könnte schon sein,
dass da noch das eine oder andere
Schritt noch fehlt,
der man machen muss.
Ach so, ja, das kann,
ja, das kann sein, Sybole.
So, aber man sieht,
es funktioniert wunderbar alles.
Okay, jetzt versuchen wir mal,
einen Crit zu basteln,
für dieses,
also, dass es ein bisschen
hübscher aussieht.
Warum schaust du nicht
die ESL One Finals?
Ich wusste eben gar nicht,
dass es ESL One Finals sind.
Spielst du nur Overwatch?
Ne.
Overwatch, null, Alter.
Omega-Lull ist Overwatch.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Overwatch, das ist mir zu anstrengend,
das ist zu hart.
Overwatch ist zu, ne,
das halte ich auf Dauer nicht aus.
Wir müssen uns noch,
ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen.
Alles Sache müssen wir noch basteln.
Man sieht auch,
wie es wieder ausgeht.
Ist euch das aufgefallen, YouTube?
Es geht an und es geht automatisch,
update und das macht es wieder aus.
Okay, ja, ich wollte,
ich wollte das Web-Interface
ein bisschen hübsch machen.
Ja, seid bei meinen krassen HTML-Künsten dabei.
Man sieht es hier ja schon.
Das ist so schlimm, ey.
Ich gucke mir das jetzt ab.
Also es hat nämlich jemand
einen Pull-Request aufgemacht.
Die Rotation-Speed-Geschichten
machen wir noch irgendwann im nächsten Mal.
Doch, habe ich, habe ich.
Ist das von dir, Queenie?
Ist das, bist du das?
Äh, so, doch kurz auf.
Wie hat er das gemacht
mit dem Crit hier?
Ja, guck mal da.
So funktioniert das.
Crit, Crit-Template.
Sind das, sind das Columns?
Acht Spalten?
Was zum Teufel ist ein FR?
Okay, alle CSS-Profis sind jetzt gefragt,
was ist ein FR?
Okay, der Alligator erklärt uns das jetzt.
Was ist ein FR?
Was, was ist, okay, was?
Fractional Unit, aha.
Ach so, one part of available space.
So Ideen kommen die auch nur, ne.
Man könnte da auch ein Prozent hinschreiben.
Warum macht man nicht einfach ein Prozent hin?
Ganz ehrlich, warum, warum FR
und warum kein Prozent?
Wahrscheinlich weil das Browser-Zeug
muss halt kompliziert sein.
Okay, Crit, wir brauchen einen Crit.
Content-Crit.
Was macht der denn da eigentlich?
Ach so, alle.
Der macht das auch noch
für unterschiedliche Bildschirmpreile.
Oh ne, das ist mir zu entwanzend.
Ich will jetzt erstmal so gucken,
wie man das macht.
Was Prozent und FR ist nicht?
Was ist denn der Unterschied
zwischen Prozent und FR?
Also so wie ich das,
ich hab das gerade so interpretiert,
dass quasi FR vom verfügbaren Speicher
one part of available space, ein Prozent.
Würde ich schon sagen.
Was ist denn der maximale
available space?
Ist es dann nicht 100?
Weil man muss es ja von irgendwas angeben.
Also eins von wieviel,
und wenn es dann nicht 100 ist.
Aber ihr wisst das wahrscheinlich besser als ich,
weil ich hab von Webzeug nur begrenzt.
Ahnung.
So, Content-Crit.
So machen wir das jetzt hier.
Ich geh mal davon aus,
dass hier ist das Wichtige.
Okay, wir machen das natürlich alles inline,
alles in einer Datei.
Ich muss euch ja noch was zeigen.
Nachdem ich ja wollte,
dass das alles in einer Datei ist
und man quasi die App runterlädt
und sonst nichts,
hatte ich ein Problem,
weil ich habe hier meine Index-HTML
und die muss ja irgendwo hin.
Die muss ich mit ausliefern
und die muss irgendwo hin.
Deswegen hab ich Trick 17 gemacht.
Pass mal auf.
Ich hab gesagt,
Index-HTML, embedded,
also sprich, die ist dann
bei der Exe mit dabei, da drinnen.
Ich denk mal, 4fr gleich 25%.
Ach so, Mason.
Ach so ist das.
Ach so.
Man sagt quasi, wie viel gibt's
und das ist dann so und so viel
vom verfügbaren Speicher
und davon kann man dann wieder
mit 3 Stück quasi 3 von dem,
was ich vorher angegeben hab.
Ach so.
Ah ja, okay.
Okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Das verstehe ich, ja.
So, genau.
Ich wollte das jetzt mit der Index-HTML zeigen,
weil es ist...
Es ist so, wir haben es jetzt.
Wir haben eine eigene Web-Interface-Klasse mittlerweile.
Ist die Schrift so gut lesbar
oder kann ich noch einen Ticken kleiner machen,
weil ich sehe so wenig.
Wir haben jetzt eine eigene Web-Interface-Klasse.
Das hab ich hier nicht on stream gemacht.
Das hab ich schon morgen hier gemacht.
Und soll ich kurz erzählen,
wie das Web-Interface funktioniert?
Oder wollen wir HTML weiter machen?
Oder soll ich vorher nochmal kurz erklären,
wie das Web-Interface back-end-technisch funktioniert?
Also es ist nicht großartig kompliziert.
Das Web-Interface besteht natürlich aus 2 Dingen.
Das besteht aus einem HTML-Java-Script-CSS-Ding.
Und halt irgendwo dort, wo der Server läuft.
Was dann letztendlich auch die Bilder
auf eurem Rechner anzeigt.
Weil das Web-Interface ist ja, wie gesagt,
gedacht, dass man es eben nicht
von dem gleichen Streaming-Rechner aus bedient,
sondern eben vom Tablet-Smartphone oder dem zweiten Rechner.
Erklären, also...
Ich mach mal einen Ticken kleiner,
sonst sieht man so wenig.
Ich guck mir das mal in der Vorschau an, ob das okay ist.
Mach mal so.
Ich muss mir das jetzt in der Vorschau angucken.
Meine Vorschau läuft nicht.
Meine Vorschau ist broken.
Okay, meine Vorschau geht nicht.
Super.
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Ja.
Also meine Vorschau ist kaputt,
aber das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach mal so passen, denke ich.
Die Größe ist super.
Okay, da muss ich nicht noch weiter machen.
Also von der Idee her funktioniert das folgendermaßen.
In meinem Haupt...
In meinem Main-Window, was man nicht sieht.
Also das hier...
Läuft das gerade noch oder hängt das noch?
Also mein Main-Window, das sieht man nicht.
Aber ich meine, da, wo die Bilder drin angezeigt werden,
das unsichtbare Fenster halt.
Das ist ein maximiertes unsichtbares,
durchlässiges Fenster hier,
wo man durchklicken kann und
nicht mit interagieren.
Aber es ist ein Fenster, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht.
Es ist halt Windows.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und...
Ja, das hat ein Tray-Menü.
Jetzt mal auf.
Das hat ein Tray-Menü.
Und das Tray-Menü hat zwei Items.
Einmal...
Das ist so klein.
Einmal für Exit.
Also sprich, das Ganze geht aus.
Und...
Dann einmal zum Starten und Stoppen vom Web-Interface.
Bei der Gelegenheit könnten wir eigentlich gleich noch einbauen,
dass er den Browser aufmacht, sobald man das startet.
Weil will man das überhaupt?
Das nicht.
Ähm, okay.
Vielleicht sollte ich hier noch hinschreiben.
Start Stop Server
Port 5001.
Schreiben wir noch dahinter.
Sonst wartet keiner eine Ahnung, auf welchen Port er muss,
wenn er nicht gerade in die ReadMe guckt.
So, wenn man hier draufklickt,
dann macht er Folgendes.
Er sagt Web-Interface Start Stop.
Also sprich, das ist dann die Web-Interface-Klasse.
Und die sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Das ist im Prinzip das, was wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben.
Bloß ausgelagert.
Das letzte Mal haben wir das ja ganz eklig hier im Main-Window drinne gemacht.
Jetzt haben wir da eine eigene Klasse draus gemacht.
Und zwar funktioniert die folgendermaßen.
Man übergibt hier erstmal beim Erstellen das...
Das Meme-Repo.
Also da, wo halt auch was dann feststellt,
ob in dem Ordner Bilder gelöscht wurden
und neue hinzugefügt oder geändert oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das braucht das Ding, dass es halt mitkriegt,
wenn sich was ändert an den Bildern unten drunter.
So.
Danach startet das...
Danach startet das ein Web-Server auf Port 5001.
Es mappt die URL unter slash image
auf unseren Meme-Ordner.
Also da kann der Browser danach drauf zugreifen.
Und unser HTML-File mappt das halt.
Wenn man auf HTML, also slash HTML slash index HTML geht,
dann kommt man halt auf die Startseite von dem Ding drauf.
Und das Ganze läuft auf Port 5001.
So.
Genau. Dann hat man die Webseite.
Und auf der Webseite ist JavaScript drauf.
Eine JavaScript-Library von Microsoft drauf,
die sich dann zu unserem...
Die sich dann auf Port 5001 dahin verbindet.
Und hier auf diesem Hub...
Also das ist jetzt nur so die High-Level-Erklärung des Ganzen.
Und dann hier halt Dinger aufruft.
Zum Beispiel, wenn sich ein Client connectet,
dann kriegt er initial erst mal alle verfügbaren Weems geschickt.
Braucht er ja, weil er hat da nichts geladen.
Und wenn der Client ein Bild anklickt,
also wenn ich im Browser ein Bild anklicke,
dann ruft das JavaScript im Browser auf dem Server hier diese Funktion auf.
Diese Funktion ruft dann hier wieder dieses Event auf.
Und dieses Event ist dann hier drinnen, wieder in meinem Main-Window verknüpft.
Da.
Und er macht im Prinzip genau das Gleiche,
wie wenn man die passende Taste drückt dazu.
Also sprich, ich blende das entweder ein oder aus.
Aber wenn das interessiert,
dann kann sich das auf GitHub genau angucken, alles.
Zumindest ist es jetzt nicht mehr im Main-Window drin,
nicht mehr ganz so eklig wie das letzte Mal auch.
So.
Genau, und dann...
Ja, genau, Trick 17 wollte ich ja noch erzählen,
wie ich das mit der Index-HTML gemacht habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das schön so ist oder ob man das so machen darf.
Es funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Und ich kann das Ding als einzelne Exe verteilen,
ohne dass man irgendwo was anderes machen muss.
So, und zwar, ich habe die Index-HTML hier embedded als Ressource quasi in meiner Anwendung drinnen.
Wenn ich das Ding ausführe, muss ich das ja aber irgendwo hinlegen.
Weil, sonst könnte ich ja nicht mit dem Browser die Datei aufrufen.
Die muss hier irgendwo sein, die muss hier irgendwo liegen.
Das bringt nichts.
Der Browser kann keine Datei öffnen, die hier irgendwo eingebunden in meiner Exe drin ist.
Das muss irgendwo liegen, auf irgendeinem Ordner muss das liegen.
Und da habe ich das jetzt einfach so gemacht.
Ich entpacke, wenn ich den Server starte, also das Ding auf Port 5001,
wenn ich das starte, entpacke ich die Index-HTML in das Temp-Verzeichnis.
Ich mache einen neuen Ordner.
Ich mache einen neuen Ordner im Temp-Verzeichnis, Firma MemeBoard.
In dem MemeBoard-Ordner entpacke ich die Index-HTML.
Und dann sage ich meinem Web-Server hier, guck mal, hier ist dein HTML Zeug.
So, und das macht er jedes Mal mal am Starten.
Weiß nicht, ob das schön ist oder sonst was, aber es funktioniert.
Und ich kann das alles in einer Exe rausballern.
So, machen wir mal HTML-Krampel.
Okay, CSS-Quiz, jetzt kommen meine krassen Frontend-Skills.
Ich kann auch mal einloggen hier auf Streamlabs, dass ich nichts verpasse.
Ja, danke schonmal für die Follows.
So, CSS-Quiz, wie macht man das jetzt?
Hör mal weg, piss dich, Alter.
Meine Katze heute Morgen, das war der piss dich, alte Blick des Todes.
Guckt mal.
Das ist mein Sofa, hau ab.
Guckt euch das mal an, wenn euch die Katze so anguckt.
Da wisst ihr irgendwas stimmt nicht.
Und davor?
Und davor wollte sie Mäuse fangen im Wohnzimmer.
Da waren halt keine, aber sie war der Meinung, da waren welche.
Also ihr müsst, da wo ich fotografiert hab, also quasi Richtung Katze, hier ist das Sofa.
Und unter dem Sofa ist halt, da ist halt ein bisschen Platz, ist halt dunkel unterm Sofa.
Und da war sie irgendwie furchtbar interessiert, ob da nicht irgendwelche Mäuse unter dem Sofa sind.
Aber die sieht echt aus, da sieht man mal wie dick die ist.
Meine Katze heißt ja viel zu schwer.
Was ist das für ne richtige Wurst?
Jetzt guckt euch das mal an.
Wurstkatze.
Okay, Crit.
Also Content-Crit, ich geh mal davon aus, das hier ist das Spannende.
100% Display-Crit, Crit-Gap, wahrscheinlich zwischen den einzelnen Elementen oder sowas.
Crit-Template-Column-Suri.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß nicht was es genau macht, aber das wird schon klappen.
Von der Alten gibt es ja ein paar ganz coole Bildchen.
Wie kann man eigentlich, was mir gerade einfällt, das daneben muss man weg, geh weg.
Wie kann man eigentlich Visual Studio einstellen, dass das HTML keine Tabs macht, sondern nur doppelte, nur zwei Leerzeichen Einrückungen?
Das geht doch bestimmt.
Kann man da irgendwas machen? HTML.
HTML.
Ne, also ich weiß nicht wie das funktioniert.
Tja, wie geht das?
Tabs, ah ja, hier.
Zwei.
Insert Spaces.
Ha, jawoll, so ist das doch viel besser.
So ist das viel besser.
Aber ein bisschen mehr Platz, kann ich auch noch ein bisschen größer machen.
So, also, Crit. Wir machen das alles inline und zwar alles mit meinem Raw-Vanilla-Java-Script-Zeugs.
Wir haben keine großartigen JavaScript-Libraries, keine komischen Kleinzeit-Frameworks.
Wir machen hier Raw-DOM in 2K18, Mama.
Vielleicht machen wir das in Zukunft noch ein bisschen schöner, wenn es ein bisschen mehr macht, außer einfach nur Bildchen anzeigen.
Mit irgendwelchen neuen Special-Kleinzeit-Frameworks wie Vue.js oder Angular oder irgendwie so Reakt.
Wobei ich glaube Vue.js ist der heiße Scheiß aktuell.
Wobei das bei Javascript ziemlich schwierig ist, da den Überblick zu behalten, weil da ist laufend was Neues.
Also sprich, wenn heute Vue.js angesagt ist, heißt das nicht, dass es morgen noch angesagt ist.
Ach Moment, was mache ich denn da? Skript? Das ist nicht Skript, das ist Style.
Lull.
100% is not valid. Bam.
Warum? Weil man das zusammen beschreibt.
Ha! Und man man das auch zusammen beschreibt. Der hat das komisch copy und pastet. Warum macht der sowas?
Oh, jetzt ist alles valid.
Voll valid.
Ich schreibe das mal klein.
Einfach nur Crit. So, mehr brauchen wir net.
Okay.
Also wenn ich das hier jetzt richtig verstehe.
Ach so, LekoArts. Okay.
Dann mal die 1fr vom freien Platz. Vom freien Platz wird jeweils automatisch die Crit-Gap abgezogen. Prozent wird sich auf die gesamte Breite beziehen.
Aha.
Also, das heißt jetzt quasi, es gibt 10 Columns, die jeweils 1fr breit sind. Oder?
Ja, genau. Okay, ja verstehe.
Ist dann der Pullgequest-Ersteller hier.
Aus dem ich mich hier grad bediene.
Ich gucke, dass ich die Dinge irgendwie noch gemerged kriege, weil es ist ja immer schwierig, wenn ich da jetzt auf Offstream dran rumgebastelt habe, da passt das ja gar nicht mehr zu dem, was ja was eingecheckt wurde.
So, okay.
Ja, Crit. Okay, das heißt wir verpassen jetzt erstmal diesem Diff hier.
Dem Diff.
Verpassen wir erstmal jetzt das als Class die...
Oder? Ja. Genau.
Wir verpassen jetzt erstmal dem Diff hier. Wo ist denn das Diff? Da.
Wobei wir können das einfach auch hier, wenn das Ding schon eh ID-Content hat, können wir das Ding auch mal Content nennen.
Da aber dann ID-Content.
Da müsste das ja automatisch passen.
So, was passiert jetzt eigentlich? Wollen wir mal gucken, wie es jetzt aussieht. Einfach mal checken, ja.
Gucken, wie es jetzt aussieht.
Start, Stop.
Naja.
Also, man sieht schon mal prinzipiell, dass das funktioniert.
Ja, das funktioniert prinzipiell. Ja, das ist doch nice, doch easy.
Gucken, jetzt spackt es auch nicht rum, wenn man das resized.
Nicht wie vorher.
Jetzt ist das ordentlich.
Klar, wenn man es zu klein macht, gibt es nicht mehr, aber...
Ich glaube, es hat heute keiner mal ein 800 x 600 Monitor.
Das ist doch mal sehr schick schon.
Okay, das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus.
So, und das ist hier ein bisschen viel Abstand dazwischen, würde ich sagen.
Okay, wir probieren jetzt noch mal, dass wir, Big Brain, dass wir noch unter das Bild, unter das Bild hier,
schreiben wir noch den Shortcut und den Dateinamen.
Und in einem der nächsten Streams machen wir das dann ein bisschen mehr fancy.
Da machen wir oben irgendwie noch so eine Searchbox oder so was hin, wo man dann suchen kann.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, man hat da irgendwie, übertreiben wir mal, 150 Bilder drin und man sucht eins,
dann ist das mit einer Searchbox natürlich ein bisschen einfacher.
Aber das auch heute nicht, weil ich muss erst mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
JavaScript, lol.
Oh, ist das hässlich, ey. Ach Gott, ist das schlimm.
So hässlich, wie ich das gemacht habe.
Aber weißt du, das ist halt JavaScript.
Dafür wäre Bootstrap schick. Ja, das stimmt schon, aber...
Ich meine, einfach, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht komplett das Bootstrap reinhauen hier für so ein publishes Quid.
So, und jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, wie machen wir das jetzt?
Also ich will hier unten drunter den Shortcut und die in der Teilnahme stehen haben.
Die kriege ich schon. Name habe ich hier am Start und übrigens hier...
Hoffentlich werde ich nicht gebannt, weil ich das Bild hier verknüpft habe für das Audio-Icon.
Also das heißt, wir brauchen da jetzt sowas wie einen...
einen Diff brauchen wir. Oh Gott, wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit?
Wir brauchen einen Diff. Also von der Idee her muss ich jetzt, ja, dass das funktioniert, muss ich jetzt...
Also jetzt ist es aktuell so, das ist jetzt einfach ein Diff mit zehn Bildern drin.
So, und wenn ich jetzt unter die Bilder was schreiben will, dann muss das nicht nur das Image-Element sein, sondern es muss ein Diff sein.
Und da drin das Image-Element und zwei Absätze Text.
Ja, ob das so funktioniert.
Machen wir das jetzt? Okay, ich mache mal irgendwas, was mir gerade so einfällt.
Also wir brauchen einen Diff. Gibt es eigentlich eine schönere Möglichkeit hier HTML-Elemente zu erstellen als so?
Weil ja, außer irgendein JavaScript-Framework, das ist mir schon klar, da könnte man irgendwelche Templates anlegen oder sowas. Und wir brauchen irgendwie den Paracraft für Text.
Machen wir das mal so. Das wird jetzt... Wir machen jetzt hässliches JavaScript noch hässlicher.
Das ist unser Ziel heute.
So, wir erpennten das Image nicht ans oberes Element, sondern unser Diff.
Und da erpennten wir dann das Diff dran.
So, und nun müssen wir uns noch einen Absatz zusammen basteln.
Irgendwie, was schreiben wir da hin? Shortcut oder sowas.
Shortcut, Control. Übrigens, wenn ihr irgendwas seht, wie man das schöner machen kann, sagt Bescheid. Wie gesagt JavaScript ist nicht meins.
Was sagen wir jetzt hier? Prefix ist unser... Ich zeige es mal. Prefix ist das, wo der Shortcut drin steht.
Wie kriege ich denn da jetzt eine Newline rein? So? Oder geht das anders? Also, so? Oder wie kriege ich denn da jetzt schön eine neue Zeile rein?
Ich mach das mal so, das wird schon irgendwie funktionieren.
So, und auf der nächsten Zeile schreiben wir jetzt rein Dateiname plus Name. Okay, dann sagen wir P. So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt geht.
Lol. Ha! Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht. Jetzt kann man sogar einen Shortcut nachgucken.
Na, wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr weiß, dass mein Shortcut für... Was weiß ich?
Dass mein Shortcut für Confused-Steuerung W ist, kann ich dann im zweiten Recht danachgucken. Anders drücken.
Oder ich kann natürlich auch im zweiten Recht hier klicken. Ja, das geht natürlich auch. Das war schon mal ganz gut.
Ich meine, es sieht jetzt zwar... Es sieht nicht schöner aus, aber es sieht auch nicht hässlicher aus, oder?
Vielleicht sollte man noch eine Schrift einblenden. Einen extra... Einen ordentlichen Font.
Hat der hier einen Font drinne? Ja.
Das ist halt nicht Times New Roman oder sowas. Das sieht halt immer kacke aus.
Name braucht man nicht. Na ja.
Na ja, ich sag mal so, wenn man jetzt hier zum Beispiel... Hier zum Beispiel hat man jetzt einen Text-to-Speech.
Und wenn jetzt nicht der Name dabei steht, weiß man da gar nicht, was das für ein Text-to-Speech ist, weil Text-to-Speech hat immer nur das Musik-Icon.
Was zockst du momentan? Also eigentlich, ich spiel ab und zu mit dem Ejax.
Spielen wir Realm Royale, wobei wir auch schon eine Weile nicht gespielt haben.
Ansonsten gerade relativ wenig.
Ich hoffe ja, dass das neue Battlefield was taugt, wenn es rauskommt.
Die Beta war jetzt ja so halb halb.
Okay, der Mason da blickt durch, der weiß was Sache ist.
Das vererbt sich doch alles, ne? Wenn ich das auf das Crit haue, kriegt es alle Elemente darunter auch.
Kannst ja wenn type Text den Namen ausgeben. Ja, das stimmt, da hast du recht.
Das könnte man machen, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, okay, die Schrift sieht doch schon viel schöner aus.
Machen wir noch Font-Size. Machen wir noch Font-Size rein und ein bisschen kleiner.
Machen wir noch irgendwie Font-Size. Font-Size.
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile Java-Script technisch schön?
Das ist ja verpönt, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Das ist ja verpönt mittlerweile, wenn man Schriftgröße in Pixel angibt.
Allerdings weiß ich auch nicht, was die nicht verpönte Variante ist.
Habe ich mir sagen lassen letztens von jemand, dass man Schriftgröße nicht mehr in Pixel eingeben soll in Java-Script.
EM, kann es sein.
EM ist doch die Geschichte, die abhängig ist von DPI vom Bildschirm und sowas, gell.
Rem? Was ist Rem?
Oh, bisschen groß vielleicht.
Rem? Oder meinst du EM?
Rem als Einheit für Schriftgröße nutzen.
Okay, Frontend Zeugs ist immer wieder gut für Überraschungen.
Das ist jetzt der Unterschied.
Gut EM, das sagt mir jetzt auch relativ wenig, was das sein soll.
Das ist der Unterschied. Die Netzspezialisten, die erklären uns das jetzt.
Die Einheit Rem ist identisch mit der Einheit, aber mit einem kleinen extra Dreh.
Das Element, auf den sich die Einheit bezieht, ist das Route-Element.
Ach, das meinst du, okay.
Ja, was heißt das jetzt?
Ach so.
Also sprich, wenn man quasi was globales gesetzt hat, dann kann man quasi abhängig zu dem seine Schriftgröße ändern.
Ach so, ah ja.
Ja, das ist, da muss ich Motto 6.9.3 geben, das ist Big Brain.
Das ist wirklich, das ist schon der Expanding Brain eigentlich, Rem zu verwenden.
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen klein jetzt.
Haben wir mal 5.
Und auch ein Busy, haben wir mal 8.
Übrigens, es ist total behämmert, dass ich jedes Mal reloade.
Ich könnte einfach die HTML-Datei editieren und Browser refreshen.
Und auch nicht mal das. Man könnte sich auch irgendeinen Browser-Plugin installieren, was für einen refresht.
Ja, das ist doch schick so.
Das lassen wir, die Größe, die Größe ist nicht schlecht.
So, und dann könnten wir noch machen, was eben jemand vorgeschlagen hat.
Einfach im Browser die Font-Size testen, richtig, ja, das hätten wir noch machen können.
Ja, eben hat jemand noch gesagt, man könnte ja auch nur den Name anzeigen lassen, wenn der Type Text ist.
Das können wir machen. Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Ich habe hier nämlich eingestellt, dass der, äh, warte, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Warte mal, wie zeige ich euch das jetzt am besten?
Wir machen, wir geben mal alles aus hier.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Das war ganz schön der Akt, bis das funktioniert hat. Vor allem, bis ich das rausgekriegt habe, wie das geht.
So, und zwar haben wir hier nämlich dabei stehen, Type, Type Image und bei, äh, ja, Moment, wo ist es? F11.
Moment, wo ist es? Dann bin ich jetzt blöd.
Ah ja, und hier ist Type Text-to-Speech.
Darkseam für das Meanboard, das schreibe ich mir auf, das brauchen wir, Darkseam brauchen wir, Leute, unbedingt.
Ohne Scheiß, ich kann jetzt überhaupt nicht ab, wenn irgendwas nicht Darkseamed ist.
Das müssen wir noch machen, ja, Darkseam, das machen wir.
So, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt gucken, ob Type Text ist.
Wie ich das reingekriegt habe, diesen Type, das war gar nicht so einfach.
Und zwar haben wir hier auf unserer Server-Seite im Base 16 Tomorrow Night Scheme.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch meine Konsolen, mein Terminal, die beste.
Wir haben ja hier diesen I-Namen drinnen, der Type von dem Ding, und da gibt es hier als Auswahl Image und Text-to-Speech.
Kann man später noch erweitern, vielleicht kann das Ding irgendwann Videos abspielen und so was.
Darkseam können wir heute auch noch machen, da muss ich mir mal überlegen, wie wir das machen,
weil dann brauchen wir irgendeinen Schalter, irgendeinen Button, wo man draufklickt, wo es dann Darkseamed.
Da müsste er mir helfen bei, weil da hören dann meine JavaScript-Frontend-Ideen auf, wie man das gescheit machen kann.
Gerade mal nachgesehen habe, vor sieben Jahren angefangen, deinem Kanal zu folgen.
Das ist ja quasi ein Jahr, nachdem ich angefangen habe, ungefähr.
Nee, eineinhalb Jahre.
Man mag es in welcher Sprache programmieren, das ist C-Sharp, und Frontend ist halt leider Gottes Nummer Javascript.
Also das Web-Interface ist halt Javascript.
Genau, und das Problem war jetzt, dass der, wenn er dieses Memo-Objekt nimmt und zum Client schickt,
das macht er hier, Web-Interface Send Update.
Hier macht er was, hier schickt er die Liste zum Client und der serialisiert standardmäßig nur Enums als Int.
Also da steht dann nicht im Web, dann kommt nicht beim Client an irgendwie Memetypes-Image oder TTS, sondern 0 und 1.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Und da musste man, jetzt wird es echt abgedreht, da habe ich eine halbe Stunde gesucht, bis ich das gefunden habe,
da musste man hier angeben, das ist wirklich absolut Magic, ja, komplett Magic.
Da musste man hier angeben, add JSON-Protokoll, options, payload, serializer, settings, converter, add, string, Enum-Converter.
Ich habe das nicht selbst rausgekriegt, muss ich gleich sagen, das habe ich Stack Overflow.
Aber the fuck, das ist absolut arcane Magie, komplett Arcane Magic hier, dass das dann funktioniert und so die Sachen keine Inps mehr sind,
sondern die Enum-Strings.
Wunderbar, aber wenn das funktioniert, ist es nice.
So, jetzt machen wir erstmal das mit dem, dass hier unten der Text nur noch da steht, wenn es type.
Für den Theme-Switch könnte man es jetzt als Custom Properties benutzen, könnte man machen.
Wann crying das mal wieder?
Er hat es mal zum BDO.
Ich habe schon ewig nicht mehr BDO gespielt, also ich logge ab und zu ein und hole Reward, aber richtig gespielt.
Der Fabian spielt ja auch gerade nicht.
Und eigentlich spiele ich das Game ja auch nur wegen dem Fabian.
Move to Payload.
So, also, dann machen wir das jetzt mal.
Wir wollen den Text nur anzeigen.
Also wir wollen auch nie, aber das wird immer eklig an das JavaScript-Zeug.
Also sprich, wenn type gleich Text to Speech.
So.
Wie macht man String-Interpolation JavaScript?
Geht das? Kann man irgendwie sowas hier machen?
Und dann gucken.
Geht das?
Dass ich das jetzt irgendwie sag zu meme type.
Geht das irgendwie?
Warte mal, ich muss mal gucken.
Da können wir uns nämlich das if sparen.
Backticks.
Die lassen aber auch kein Zeichen auf der Tastatur aus oder was man verwenden kann.
Das ist neu.
Das gibt es ja nicht so lange.
Das habe ich nämlich noch nicht gesehen bis jetzt.
Das muss neu sein.
Also kann ich jetzt hier quasi sagen.
Also nur mal von der Idee her.
Ich könnte jetzt hier quasi sagen meme type gleich TTS.
Wenn das TTS ist, dann.
Okay, das ist auch nicht schöner sonst.
Ist auch nicht schöner so.
Dann könnte ich dann quasi sagen, wenn das so ist, dann sagen wir name.
Das funktioniert.
Nee, guck mal, das das funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe das das stimmt nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Oder ist das Highlighting kaputt?
Ach so.
Ja klar.
Ich muss ja auch den Ausdruck fertig machen.
Name gleich.
Ich blicke da mal durch.
Jetzt müsste ich da drin.
Interpolation.
Interpol.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Was zum Teufel?
Nee, nee, das machen wir so nicht.
Geht das so?
Es sieht kacke aus.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ja.
Es funktioniert.
Habt ihr denn?
Oh, Auskennfuchs.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Das ist nämlich viel besser.
Zeig mal, zeig mal her.
Ja.
Gut, dass du den Campel gelöscht hast.
Da war ich überhaupt nicht so so.
Ach so, was gibt's?
Ach.
Hätte ich das mal gewusst.
Ach so.
Ja, das ist doch viel besser.
Nice.
Wusste ich nicht, dass das gibt.
Ja, das merchen wir jetzt gleich mal.
Was ist hier mit dem Projekt-File kaputt?
Ja gut, das ist die neue Zeug.
Alles Zeug.
Ja, das merchen wir jetzt.
Was ist zwar etwas off-topic, aber hast du noch deinen Raspberry Pi...
Nee, lohnt sich nicht.
Sackt.
Also für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist, ich zeig das mal kurz.
Das ist eigentlich das Wichtige, dass es mit Blacklist ist.
Das Problem ist, an sich ist die Idee gut.
Und man muss es auch nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi installieren.
Man kann es sich auch in der VM oder so installieren.
Das muss nicht auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass das anders als zum Beispiel ein Werbeblocker im Browser,
der das quasi rausfiltert aus dem HTML.
Wenn man DNS-Anfragen blockt für bekannte Affiliate-Uls,
oder für bekannte Uls, wo es Werbung gibt, dann hängen manche Seiten.
Also sprich, wenn jetzt irgendeine Seite Werbung laden will und das funktioniert nicht,
dann hängen die.
Und das ist halt kacke.
Deswegen verwende ich das Ganze nicht mehr.
Zum Beispiel die Twitch-App auf dem Smartphone wird mit Pi-Hole unbenutzbar.
Weil das Ding ist irgendwie darauf angewiesen, sich zu connecten zu seinem Werbenetzwerk.
Und wenn es das nicht kann, hängt es einfach bei jedem Klick 30 Sekunden, bis es einen Timeout gibt.
Und das ist halt kacke.
Deswegen verwende ich das nicht mehr.
Es ist unbenutzbar.
So, aber wir merchen jetzt den Kram vom How-to-scan-Fox.
Das ist ganz toll.
Ich mach das gerade mal zu.
Kann man im Visual Studio irgendwas aktualisieren?
Was pullen oder so?
Geht das?
Weiß nicht.
Egal, wir merchen das jetzt.
Ich bin eingeloggt, ich darf das machen.
Review changes.
Ich will das nicht refuelen, ich will merchen.
Wie mercht man überhaupt den Github?
Moment.
Also ich meine, ich kann über die Konsole merchen, klar.
Aber kann man nicht auch über das Web-Interface merchen?
Ach hier.
Merch-Pool-Request.
Easy, steht auch sogar da.
Aber einfach kilometerlange Hosts hat er, die alles blockt.
Das kann man natürlich auch machen.
Was ist eigentlich das hier?
Auskenn-Fox, was hat er denn hier umgestellt?
Package-Config-Designer.
Das sind irgendwelche Visual-Studio-Settings von dir wahrscheinlich.
Aber das passt, das nehmen wir so.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir merchen das jetzt mal.
Okay.
Bäm.
Das mercht.
Dann pullen wir mal.
Jetzt die Preisfrage.
Wie pullt man in Visual Studio?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht den Schimmer einer Ahnung.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt nicht über Visual Studio, sondern über die Shell.
Da weiß ich wenigstens, wie es funktioniert.
Mal einen ganzen Tag nichts anderes sonst.
So, ekliges Windows-Terminal, track and drop.
Hey Cortana, pull.
Oh, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Wie macht man Cortana an?
Oh, ich bin so ein Windows-Noob, ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Das pull, das machen wir jetzt.
Wir sagen Cortana jetzt, dass sie git pull machen soll.
Wie macht man Cortana an?
Cortana, wie geht das?
Was ist da, wo man Windows-Update macht?
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Jetzt mal real talk.
Ich sage jetzt mal, wie ich das empfinde.
Windows ist, was das Finden von Einstellungen anbelangt, der allerletzte Bodensatz.
Das ist so beschissen.
Es ist wirklich richtig beschissen.
Und es ist ja Windows 10.
Und ich finde Windows 10 an sich nicht schlecht.
Von allen Sachen ist es noch das kleinste Problem.
Jetzt, wo es noch drei, vier Menüs gibt, wo was ist, alte, neue, noch neuere.
Es ist abgrundtief scheiße, Windows-Settings zu finden.
Was rechts liegt auf Taskleiste.
Und dann Cortana.
Cortana, Cortana, Cortana.
Wie mache ich Cortana an?
Such.
Ich meine, warum?
Warum kann man nicht einfach sagen, Cortana und das starten und dann geht es auf?
Warum ist das so?
So, ich will jetzt wissen, wie das geht.
Ach, fick dich, kein Bock, Cortana.
Wir bullen jetzt so.
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich auch immer auf der Arbeit erzähle.
Viele Leute haben sich angewöhnt, anstatt Git Pull zu machen.
Anstatt die voll qualifizierte Schreibweise.
Und das Problem dabei ist, dass vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit,
Git, die default-Settings waren, bei Push.
Bei Pull bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, aber wahrscheinlich bei Pull auch.
Zumindest bei Push alle Branches, die man lokal hatte, zu pushen.
Und das will man meistens nicht.
Meistens will man nur den Branch pushen, auf dem man drauf ist.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile hat sich das Default geändert.
Also sprich, dass Git Push nur noch den Branch macht, auf dem man gerade drauf ist, standardmäßig.
Aber es war vor nicht allzu langer Zeit, war das Default-Setting.
Und da hast du teilweise Dinge gepusht, die wolltest du gar nicht pushen.
Deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt, ich schreibe immer die komplette Schreibweise hin.
Oh man.
Okay, ich mache mal Wishlist-Studie zu.
Ich glaube, das hat Probleme damit, wenn dahinter kommt, was läuft.
Okay.
Guck mal mal, was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Ach so, ja gut, kann ich machen.
Sag mal, warum sagt er mir nicht einfach hier mal bitte Konflikt?
Ach so, weil ich noch nicht committed habe.
Ich will die Änderung eigentlich auch gar nicht.
Na, wenn ich einen Git Stash machen muss, einen Git Stash Pop danach machen, dann habe ich auf jeden Fall irgendeinen Konflikt.
Wie könnte ich das jetzt wirklich clever machen?
Ich will das nicht committen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich da einen Konflikt kriege.
Kann schon sein, wenn ich das jetzt parallel geändert habe.
Ich meine, wir können das mal machen.
Das könnte ich auch machen.
Ich könnte die Datei auch wieder resetten.
Das Schöne an Git ist, man sieht es ja auch gerade im Chat, es gibt 20.000 Varianten, wie man irgendwas machen kann.
Moment.
Weil man das jetzt vergessen hat.
Sehr schön.
Pop, war das eins oder einfach nur?
Ich glaube einfach nur Pop, dann macht er das letzte.
Siehst du?
Von wegen, ich habe keinen Konflikt.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, da wird wahrscheinlich ziemlich überschaubar sein.
Oh nee, wir sind ja unter Windows.
Habe ich einen Wim drauf?
Please.
Okay, gut.
Okay, da backt ihr irgendwie rum, ich resette das jetzt einfach.
Wim Woodface, ja.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier zumindest keine.
Watt?
Ach so.
Kann ich das irgendwie so machen?
Nee.
Was ist das jetzt am besten?
Ich will eigentlich die Version nehmen.
Ich weiß, ich weiß irgendwas machen.
Kannst du das jetzt abbrechen?
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich könnte doch einfach sagen, warum geht denn das nicht?
Warum kann ich den Scheiß nicht zurücksetzen?
Auf.
So, ich weiß, jetzt habe ich den Konflikt noch drin, oder?
Also, das müsst ihr mir nicht, ich weiß, dass das nicht so gedacht ist.
Ist aber doof.
Sie ist gefuddelt da, ey.
Was ich jetzt überhaupt nicht checke ist, dass es angeblich den Merch gibt, aber dann doch nicht.
Der ist noch Merch, the fuck, warum nicht?
Okay, jetzt machen wir ein Checkout.
Okay.
Beste.
Watt?
Warum ist der Scheiß jetzt noch drin?
Jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt.
Habe ich das Ding schon schon kommited oder was?
Was hat das Ding für Schmerzen?
Warum geht das nicht?
Oder wie ist überhaupt die richtige Schreibweise?
Checkout von das so.
Aha.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich nicht die letzte.
Okay, gucken wir, gucken wir, gucken wir, ob der Krempel jetzt einfach funktioniert.
Wenn ich risiätisch den Kram noch mal gut ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe mehr Zeit damit verpackt, die Treppe zu fixen, wie zu programmieren.
Wobei es geht, es geht eigentlich.
Also wenn man den meisten Leuten für die wichtigen Branchen das Push-Berechtigung wegnimmt, dann ist es kein Problem.
Es ist immer noch ein Problem, wenn alle dürfen und alle rumwursten.
Okay, anscheinend war das jetzt okay und geht jetzt.
Was auch immer.
So, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, ob das geht.
Jetzt habe ich das vom letzten Komet.
Und jetzt ist es von diesem Komet.
Gucken wir, ob das vom Auskenn-Fuchs ist oder vom Auskenn-Fuchs.
Okay, nice, gut.
Dann passt alles, dann haben wir jetzt das Richtige.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Max, hast du dir doch die erste Staffel von der Serie You Are Wanted angesehen mit dem Schweighöfer? Hast dich auch die zweite schon gewagt oder auch gleich gelassen?
Nein, habe ich nicht geguckt.
Ich habe auch die erste nicht ganz geguckt.
Also das war jetzt so doof, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat das ja eine super Auflösung gehabt, aber das war für mich so eine gewollt und nicht gekonnt Geschichte.
Ich bin jetzt ja auch niemand, der unbedingt jetzt deutsche Produktionen schlecht reden muss.
So nach dem Motto, es ist alles scheiße.
Wir haben ja auch kreative Leute und machen auch ganz gute Sachen, aber die Serie hat mir nicht gefallen.
Und ich wusste bis jetzt gar nicht, dass es überhaupt eine zweite Staffel dazu gibt.
Da muss ich dem Sebaro Recht geben.
Ich wusste nicht mal, dass eine zweite Staffel dafür existiert.
So, okay, dann gucken wir uns mal an, was der Auskenn-Fuchs hier gemacht hat.
Oder außer sich auskennen natürlich.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Ansonsten müssen wir noch mal resetten.
Wollen wir mal nachgucken, was er hier gemacht hat.
Embedded File Provider in Web Interface.
Web Interface.
Embedded File Provider, okay.
Und das funktioniert jetzt.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Jetzt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Nein, funktioniert nicht.
Auskenn-Fuchs, das ist kaputt.
Das ist kaputt.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Was hat er denn für ein Fafikon, okay.
Aber warum ist es kaputt?
Warum ist es kaputt?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Ich meine, im Prinzip hat sich ja nichts geändert.
Die Index-Datei geht doch.
Kann das sein, dass einfach keine Memes drin sind?
Dass das gerade rumbuckt?
Da sind keine Memes drin.
Keine Panik aus, Ken-Fuchs, du hast nichts kaputt gemacht.
Da sind keine Memes mehr drin.
Logischerweise, weil ich meinen Projekt-File überschrieben habe.
Wo ich die hier reingekopiert und pastet habe.
Kein Wunder, dass das nicht geht.
Alles gut, das liegt nicht an dir.
Was?
Already exists?
Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Fake News, das existet überhaupt nicht.
Kann man dem Ding nicht sagen, Refresh Ordner mal?
Warum geht das nicht?
Kann doch nicht sein.
Naja.
F5...
Nein, F5 bringt hier glaube ich nichts drin.
F5 ist Bild.
Wishing Studio ist crap.
Nein, ich mag Wishing Studio.
Ich mag es nicht.
Wishing Studio ist crap.
Nein, ich mag Wishing Studio.
Wishing Studio ist gut.
Mir gefällt Wishing Studio.
Kann man das jetzt einfach wieder neu reinziehen?
Oder spackt es dann rum?
Wahrscheinlich spackt es rum, wenn ich jetzt neu reinziehe.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Ich kopiere den Scheiß jetzt dahin.
Dann löschen wir den Inhalt.
Dass es jetzt wieder passt.
Und jetzt troppen wir den Inhalt wieder rein.
Wishing Studio braucht das.
Das ist nicht anders.
F5 für Bild.
Mein Lieblings-
Das habe ich jetzt hier aber noch gar nicht eingestellt.
Mein Lieblings-Shortcut für Run ist Steuerung R.
Fällt mir am besten.
Steuerung R.
Kommt man schnell hin und passt irgendwie zu.
Okay, geht.
Geht wieder.
Alles gut.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Bam.
Nice.
Ausgehen, Folks.
Das brauche ich mein komisches Extract und rumkopieren nicht mehr.
So ist es viel besser.
Viel viel schöner.
Viel viel schöner ist das so.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Das ist eine super Geschichte, muss ich sagen.
Gefällt mir.
Da kann man das Ding direkt aus den Embedded Resources
HTML Zeug füttern.
Sehr, sehr nice. So als hätten andere Leute schon die Probleme.
Kann man dann auch das Icon abrufen?
Welches Icon?
Was?
Das Problem war,
dass er das nicht in Output kopiert hat.
Obwohl es im Ordner drin war.
Und weil es halt nicht im Output,
also weil er das nicht kannte,
die Datei, konnte er es halt auch nicht in Output kopieren.
Was ich ja nicht verstehe ist,
warum man mir nicht sagen kann, okay,
wenn in diesem Ordner was drin liegt,
Refresh mal, dass ich hier wieder Settings drin habe.
Aber was auch immer.
Beispiel Studio, die wissen schon, wie das geht.
Okay, weiter geht es.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Oder habe ich irgendwas überlesen überhaupt?
Zeig mal her.
Ich habe immer gewollt den Scheiß,
dann gebe ich mir den noch mal in der zweiten Staffel.
Oder wie fandest du es denn?
Du hast ja gefragt.
Wie fandest du es denn?
Ich meine, nur weil ich das Scheiße fand,
heißt es ja nicht,
dass auch alle Scheiße finden.
Man weiß ja nie.
So.
Weiter geht es.
Wir waren hier ursprünglich dabei.
Wo sind wir denn eigentlich gerade stehen geblieben,
bevor ich den Krämpel hier gemarcht habe?
Genau. Wir haben unser JavaScript noch hässlicher gemacht.
Ich meine, guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch nicht mal feierlich hier.
Was ist das denn?
Mr. Robot gesehen, ja, die erste Staffel.
Was war deine Lieblingsserie des letzten Jahres?
Ich habe nicht so viele geguckt.
Ich habe ein paar auf Amazon geguckt.
Lass mal überlegen, was ist denn so?
Was ist mir besonders im Kopf hängen geblieben?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Also das letzte, was ich geguckt habe,
war Preacher Staffel 2.
Ich logg mich hier gerade mal bei Amazon ein
im zweiten...
zweiten Monitor.
Kann ich nämlich mal gucken.
Preacher Staffel 2 habe ich geguckt.
Fand ich jetzt
die ersten Folgen richtig gut.
Da hat es auch richtig Zug drauf
und war spannend.
Aber dann so die zweite Hälfte hat nachgelassen.
Mr. Robot hat auch finde ich nachgelassen
in der zweiten Hälfte von der ersten Staffel.
Deswegen habe ich mir die anderen Staffeln
gar nicht mehr angeguckt.
Serien, was habe ich denn geguckt?
The Night Manager habe ich geguckt.
Genau, das fand ich gut.
Das fand ich richtig gut.
Obwohl es überhaupt keine Action großartig hatte.
Außer zwischendrin immer ein bisschen.
Aber ich mag die Schauspieler
und ich fand es auch
sehr spannend gemacht.
Also das war nice.
Das hat mir gefallen.
Ich würde sagen, das war somit das beste,
was ich dieses Jahr geguckt habe.
Das hier, ich zeige es mal kurz.
Was da?
Mit Dr. House und Loki.
Ich weiß leider nicht, wie die Typen weisen.
Amazon.
Asta.
Er fand ich nice.
Und es war eines der wenigen Serien,
die glücklicherweise komplett abgeschlossen waren.
Also von Anfang bis Ende.
Das Ende war vorbei.
Da war Schluss.
Also sprich, wenn die eine zweite Staffel machen,
können sie was komplett neues machen
oder es einfach auch sein lassen.
Weil das ist wirklich mal eine Serie, die braucht gar keine zweite Staffel.
Einfach vorbei.
Was habe ich noch geguckt?
American Gods?
Das glaube ich.
War genau so.
Erste Hälfte
geil, zweite Hälfte langweilig.
Langweilig, ja.
Das einzig Geile bei American Gods war
die letzte Folge.
Die letzten 10 Minuten der letzten Folge.
Wo Odin am Start war.
Das war auch nice.
Was habe ich noch geguckt?
Badlands.
Badlands habe ich geguckt.
Übelster Trash.
Ich würde nicht sagen Übelster Crap.
Aber
übelster Trash.
Boah, ich weiß nicht.
Wer fällt mir jetzt nicht ein?
Keine Ahnung.
Was waren denn die besten Serien, die ich geguckt habe
vor gerade der Weise?
Okay.
Wir müssen jetzt mal kurz weitermachen.
Wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Ich bin jetzt voll verwirrt.
Tablets.
Dönerpizza.
Ich hatte mal einen Dönerburger.
Es gibt
bei einem Lieferservice
in Frankfurt, gab es mal, stand
bei denen, wenn du online bestellt hast,
stand da Dönerburger.
Und habe ich mir damals bestellt.
Das war gar
nichts.
Das war gar nichts.
Also das.
Gucken ob es das noch gibt.
Taxi Baba Burger.
Nein, nein, das wäre was anderes.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Egal. Es hatte halt mit Döner überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Es war quasi irgendwie so.
Es war noch nicht mal Dönerfleisch.
Es war ein Burger.
Der Rest war quasi
Döner, also
Dönerpizza.
Das war quasi
Döner, also es war irgendwie so
dieses Krautzeug drauf
und dieses Brot und sowas. Das war im Prinzip ein Brot
mit zwei Frikadellen hinten dran.
Das hat überhaupt nicht geschmeckt.
Wenn ich türkische Frikadellen
futtern will, dann hole ich mir einen Köftesandwich
oder sowas. Das schmeckt dann auch geil.
Aber Dönerburger hat überhaupt nicht
geschmeckt. Das war also
eines der schlechtesten Sachen, die ich jemals im Lieferdienst
gewählt habe.
Okay.
Ja, Preacher fand ich nicht schlecht.
Die zweite Staffel hat nachgelassen
an der zweiten Hälfte. Ich hab letztens die Nachricht
von Amazon gekriegt, dass es jetzt auch irgendwie die dritte Staffel
oder so schon gibt. Muss ich mal gucken.
Okay, ich muss mal kurz konzentrieren.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wir wollen ein komisches Crit machen. Crit haben wir gemacht.
Wo haben wir jetzt aufgehört?
Was wollten wir machen, Leute?
Helfen wir mal auf die Sprünge.
Was wollten wir da machen?
Ah, ja.
Einen Dark Seam wollten wir noch machen, aber vorher wollten wir noch
irgendwie was anderes machen.
Also das letzte, was ich gemacht habe,
ist hier unten die
Sachen ein- und auszuplenden.
Ich mein, das ist doch jetzt ganz nice.
OMEGALUL
Ich bin immer noch begeistert,
wie der automatisch
refreshed, dass das vorbei ist.
Was wollten wir denn jetzt machen?
Ich bin voll verwirrt gerade.
Was wollten wir denn jetzt...
Was war das letzte, was ich machen wollte?
Pog. Nee, Pog habe ich nicht.
Leider habe ich alle
Bella Twitch TV Emotes schon aufgebraucht.
Ja, geht nicht.
Vielleicht sollte man das umbenennen von PlupTXT
in OMEGALUL.
Den Bitcoin Miner...
Das zeige ich euch natürlich nicht auf Stream, oder?
Das ist auf einmal bescheuert.
Den bau ich ein,
wenn ihr nicht mehr zuguckt.
Den Bitcoin Miner.
Inklusive Keylogger und Remote Zugriff.
Ethereum Miner, Monero Miner,
Ripple Miner, kann man dafür überhaupt
meinen, keine Ahnung, Miner.
Alles Miner. So wie Cristiano Ronaldo,
der hatte auf seiner Webseite auch, ich glaube,
Ethereum hat er gemeint,
oder sowas. Kannst du dem
Diff mal einen BG-Color geben?
Ja, könntest du mal... Achso, Darkseam
wollten wir machen, genau. So, Leute.
Nachdem ich davon wirklich
keine Ahnung habe,
wie man sowas JavaScript-mäßig möglichst
simpel macht, brauche ich jetzt
eure Hilfe. Das heißt, wir müssen das jetzt
zusammen irgendwie bewältigen.
Und zwar...
Ähm...
Wir machen einen Button.
CodePen.
Ok, mach ich, ich mach das mal auf.
Darklight-Switch.
Ok, Copy-Paste.
Copy-Pasta.
Serious Max, das... alles.
So.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Just press the button above to toggle.
Progress! So.
So brauch ich das. So muss das sein.
So will ich das haben.
Darkseam.
Das brauchen wir.
Wir brauchen unbedingt einen Darkseam.
Das geht nicht ohne. Das ist nicht möglich.
Ohne Dark... Guckt mal, überlegt euch mal,
ihr spielt was.
Und dann müsst ihr auf einmal...
Überlegt euch mal, ihr habt hier sowas auf.
Ihr spielt halt hier irgendwie...
Bam, in your face, in your face.
Und dann guckt ihr auf den zweiten Monitor.
Also das geht nicht. Deswegen braucht es
ein Darkseam.
Ok. Wir...
Wo hast du denn das her? Wir hatten das gepostet.
Max. Ist das... ist das eben von Stack
Overflow oder hast du das gerade gebastelt?
Ok. Das heißt wir brauchen
erstmal einen Button.
Aha. Body ID.
Body ID. Body...
But why? Achso. Damit, dass man das
austauschen kann.
War von Stack Overflow. Ok. Wie funktioniert
denn der Gram jetzt mal?
Lass mal in Ruhe angucken. Ok.
Das ist ein Button mit einem On-Click.
On-Click zu dem hier.
Selber basteln.
Türkiye L-Team.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ok.
Was diese
Funktion macht, ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes
wie das
Body Element sich schnappen.
Gucken, wie die
aktuelle CSS-Klasse ist.
Und dann
schauen,
wenn Curve Class Dark Mode ist,
dann zu Light Mode switchen. Und wenn
es eben nicht so ist, dann zu Dark Mode switchen.
Ok. Das ist simpel. Das krieg ich. Das check ich.
Ok. Wir copypasten uns
das jetzt schon mal rein.
Kann man eigentlich
so globale... kann man so Sachen
hier oben irgendwie drin definieren?
Ok. Das heißt mein Body, der braucht
auch die Body, dass ich den finde.
Aha. So.
Und da machen wir jetzt hier den Button.
Class Dark Mode.
Stack Overflow Driven
Programming. Beste.
Dark Mode.
Button.
So.
Button. Da muss ich irgendwie den Button...
Ich will einfach nur testen, ob ich den Button da oben hin...
und klick.
Das da. Hoffentlich findet er das
jetzt. Und
dann müssen wir noch die CSS-Geschichten
machen.
Dark Color. Light Color.
Ach so. Ah. Man kann...
Seit wann kann man den CSS-Variablen machen?
Das ist seit CSS 3.
Ach so.
Nee, das ist...
Ah ja.
Ok. Besser.
Ok. Jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen, was braucht man davon
eigentlich? Wir wollen ja einfach nur
mal kurz gucken, ob es geht.
Body Dark Mode. Body. Body.
Body Dark Mode.
Body Light Mode. Das sind eigentlich die
zwei, die wir gerade brauchen.
Body Dark Mode.
Body Light Mode.
So. Ich will einfach gucken, was jetzt passiert, wenn man da draufklickt.
Bam. Dark Mode.
Schreckt.
Eats. Eats as fuck, alter.
Ok. Die Rahmen sehen jetzt nicht so ganz richtig aus,
aber da können wir noch was machen.
Eats as fuck.
Hehehe.
Ok.
Krasser Effekt
mal hier zur Geltung bringen.
Ok. Ähm.
Also die Seite ist nicht wirklich
schön. Also doch. Oder? Doch, die Seite
ist schon ein bisschen schöner geworden. Doch, muss man sagen.
Ne? Leute. Bisschen schöner ist die
schon. Und außerdem macht Dark Seam alles besser.
Ok.
Ähm. Was
ihr hier gerade seht,
wir basteln,
wir machen gerade das Frontend
für
mein Streamer-Meme-Tool
etwas hübscher. Ohne, dass ich mich großartig
mit CSS und JavaScript auskenne.
Und das ist schwierig.
Warum labert da einer?
Das ist die Epic Chillstep
Collection. Da darf keiner labern.
Wo?
Das will ich printen.
Chill your mind, Radio.
Ne, da singt auch einer.
Das ist doff.
Fast doff, Leute.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
So, genug.
Ori-Soundtrack, beste.
Ups. Wat?
So. So ist das gut.
Magst du mich nicht auf Twitter entblocken?
Äh.
Kommt drauf an.
Weshalb ich dich geblockt hab.
Falls ich da ein wenig
überreagiert hab
sollte, entblock ich dich gerne.
Aber ich muss mir erst mal angucken, weshalb.
Ansonsten.
Bam.
Wie ist dein Twitter-Account?
Bestimmt schon ein paar Jahre.
Ja, post einfach mal
dein Twitter-Account.
Ich entblock dich dann.
Cortana-Flip.
Okay.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Boah, ich weiß nicht, warum ich dich geblockt hab.
Ich weiß, ich hab dich entblockt.
Oh, ich weiß, warum ich dich geblockt hab.
Soll ich's zeigen?
Ist nix Schlimmes.
Echt nix Schlimmes.
Also, du hast es nicht verdient, dafür geblockt zu werden.
Aber ich war da grad ein wenig angepisst, glaube ich.
Aber ich zeig Ihnen, warum ich dich geblockt hab.
Das ist überhaupt nix Schlimmes.
Ich sag's gleich dazu.
Eigentlich hätt ich dich dafür echt nicht blocken müssen.
Warte mal.
Das haben wir gerade echt scheiße gespielt.
Also, wie immer.
Also, ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
ich war ein wenig angepisst,
dass wir verloren haben.
Dementsprechend war ich so sauer,
dass ich wahrscheinlich jeden gebannt hab,
der irgendwas Domes draufgeschrieben hat.
Nee, das hast du nicht verdient,
dafür geblockt zu werden.
Ich vermute mal, dass wir da grad
irgendeinen ESL-Overwatch haben.
Oder dass wir da grad irgendeinen ESL-
also Overwatch-ESL oder so gespielt haben gerade.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ja, ja gut, wenn Sylas da drauf geantwortet hat.
Da haben wir gerade,
da haben wir wahrscheinlich grad
Weekly Cup gespielt und auf die Fresse gekriegt.
Ich war sauer.
Da hab ich dich gebannt,
weil du dummes Zeug draufgeschrieben hast.
Den Ban hast du nicht verdient.
Das ist jetzt wieder weg.
Warum hast du Windows auf Englisch laufen?
Die simple Begründung dafür ist,
dass wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
ich besser suchen kann.
Such mal nach deutschen Fehlermeldungen
und such mal nach englischen Fehlermeldungen.
Wo findest du schneller was?
Willst du noch sowas wie LightDB einbauen,
damit man die Memes in die DB hochladen kann,
anstatt einen Ordner?
Ja, da hab ich mir schon Gedanken drüber gemacht.
LightDB oder SQLite oder irgendwie sowas.
Und zwar werde ich das auch noch
ein bisschen umbauen aus, Ken Fuchs.
Und zwar hab ich mir das so überlegt.
Das ist jetzt ja relativ primitiv.
Das nimmt ein Ordner und Static File
und haut das Ganze raus.
Ich werde den Memes noch...
Warte mal, wo ist das denn hier?
Ich werde noch Unique IDs verpassen.
Also hier, wenn es hier angelegt wird,
kriegen die noch eine Unique ID,
die man dann auch im Frontend verwenden kann.
Und dann mach ich auch im Webinterface...
Hier kann man ja aktuell nichts uploaden.
Der haut seine Static Files raus
auf hier unter Slash Image und Gutes.
Ich werde dann...
Wenn alle Memes nur eine ID haben,
werde ich dann quasi noch
ein paar Routen registrieren
oder irgendwie einen Controller
noch reinhauen, der quasi
das Get annimmt mit der ID
bzw. auch einen Post
mit einem neuen Meme drinnen.
Und dann kann man auch über das Webinterface
neue Sachen hochladen,
die ihr dann im Hintergrund den Ordner kopiert.
Ja, ja.
Das habe ich mir schon überlegt,
sowas in der Richtung.
Wobei man dazu nicht unbedingt eine DB bräuchte.
Man kann es immer noch in Ordner kopieren
im Hintergrund.
Da kann zwar jeder dann was
hinkopieren auf den Rechner,
aber ich meine, das läuft im lokalen Netzwerk.
Wir könnten das ja auch noch Passwort schützen
oder so.
So.
Okay.
Weiter im Text.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Ich glaube, der Ori-Soundtrack
ist einfach gerade leise.
Okay, Dark Steam haben wir jetzt auch.
Das Einzige, was noch richtig
hässlich aussieht, sind die
Kästchen da drum herum.
Das machen wir jetzt noch ein bisschen anders.
Generell, warum
mache ich hier eigentlich...
Warum genau?
Was habe ich mir eigentlich dabei gedacht?
Inline mit Inline Styles gemacht.
Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt,
Sebaro.
Oder alle, die es jetzt geschrieben haben,
dass man auch quasi...
Dass man die Bilder nicht lokal braucht.
Dass man halt auch
Urls irgendwie anzeigen kann.
Dass es im Hintergrund runterliegt und dann anzeigt
und sowas.
Allerdings, das müsst ihr halt selbst dann eintragen.
Dann bin ich da fein raus, was Urheberrecht angeht.
Also, ich mach das dann irgendwie so,
dass man sagen kann,
hier diese Url, also wir erweitern ja das
Webfront dann noch ein bisschen.
Dass man dann sagen kann, diese Url will ich
dann, keine Ahnung, auf
Ctrl D oder so.
Und dann zeigt er das an.
Der PC aus Kaufberatung 2014.
Ja, nice. Da haben wir uns auch viel Gedanken
damals gemacht.
Gar nichts dabei gedacht. Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt
mal...
Wie macht man das jetzt ordentlich, CSS?
Also...
Wir gucken mal, also wir wollen auf jeden Fall
nicht...
Also wir wollen jetzt
erstmal...
Sag mal,
warum macht man jetzt eigentlich...
Warte mal,
so stylt das komplette
Body Element mit der
Class Dark Mode, ne?
Das heißt das doch in CSS, also sprich,
dass das betrifft das Body Element
und das ist nur für
Class Dark Mode.
Also das heißt doch eigentlich, könnten wir doch so was machen wie
Image,
und dann machen wir so was wie Image
TTS,
dann wird's Purple,
kann man...
Okay, Leute, jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt mal advanced.
Ich probier jetzt mal was, ich weiß nicht ob das funktioniert.
Also man könnte doch sagen,
man macht so eine Base Klasse CSS
mäßig, das ist dann sowas hier.
Oh guck mal, der formatiert das
auch, also quasi sowas hier.
Base Image, und dann, dann sagt man
quasi als nächstes
advanced.
Ja, für mich,
als JavaScript nu ist das advanced.
So, und dann sag ich
Image, Punkt, Text
to Speech, und also mit Text
to Speed Klasse
und...
und noch was anderes.
Ah, Active,
Active.
Ähm...
Active,
geht das so?
Most immersive
CSS ever, ja so ist es, so ist es.
Warum rückt der das hier
jetzt so scheiße ein?
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen
Windows, PowerShell und Eingabe
Eingabe
Aufforderung?
Ähm, die ist neuer.
PowerShell kann dort Netzzeugs
aufrufen und ist viel moderner
als
Windows.
Das einzige Problem was Windows hat
ist, dass es keine gescheite Terminal Anwendung
gibt. Also
Windows Leute verwechseln ja immer
das hier mit dem Terminal. Beziehungsweise
das hier mit dem Terminal.
Wisst ihr was ich mein?
Für jemand, der es halt nicht anders
kennt, ist das das gleiche. Quasi der Inhalt
und das Fenster ist das gleiche, das stimmt aber nicht.
Das Fenster, die Anwendung
drum ist, ist quasi der Terminal, bzw. der Terminal
Emulator, und das da drin ist die Shell,
die da drinne läuft.
Leider gibt es kein gescheites Terminal
unter Windows, standardmäßig.
Deswegen verwende ich immer CMDer,
wo das gleiche drin läuft,
wie in diesem Windows Terminal, also die gleiche
Shell.
Aber halt mit
viel besseren Sachen.
Viel, viel nicer. Git vorinstalliert
und
Suche, Reverse-Suche nach
Kommandos.
So.
Ok, ähm.
Moment, Leute, das war ja eben
quasi kein richtiges
CSS, was wir auf der Seite gesehen haben,
sondern so ein
CSS-Template-Sprache,
ne?
Also was wie SAS quasi.
Wie macht man denn jetzt Variablen in CSS3?
Also kann ich irgendwie
in CSS sagen,
dass, dass, dass
Dark
ist, geht das
irgendwie, dass ich sage, Dark ist
ähm, so?
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gehen,
aber wie, wie macht man das in CSS?
Und dann, dann sage ich hier unten irgendwie so was wie
Dark. Dark.
Dark. Dark. Dark.
Minus, minus
Name-Wert.
Also genauso wie es da steht eigentlich.
Also, okay, ich probier das jetzt mal.
Also quasi so.
Dann sagen wir jetzt hier
Ups.
Jetzt mal rückgängig machen, den Kram.
Dark.
Also sage ich jetzt so was wie
Light.
MaxLens CSS live on stream.
So.
Und dann
Ups, jetzt habe ich falsche kopiert.
Ziemlich neu, ja ja,
ich sehe es, ich sehe es.
So.
Also quasi wahr.
Man sieht es, ach guck mal, guck mal.
Ich habe sogar Autokomplete dafür.
Ja, Charakter.
Ich habe es auch gerade gemerkt.
Nice.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
So, das heißt, wenn wir das jetzt starten, geht nicht.
Es ist kaputt.
Warum ist es kaputt?
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich wieder beendet, ja.
Was haben wir denn jetzt kaputt gemacht?
Ich meine, es geht eindeutig davor kaputt,
wenn unsere JavaScript-Funktion nicht mehr defined ist.
Hm.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Ich weiß es aber nicht, durch was.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich mache das mal wieder rückgängig, kurz.
Ich weiß nicht, durch genau was ich kaputt gemacht habe,
aber ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Okay, mal gucken, ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Was?
Was habe ich denn jetzt hier kaputt gemacht?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Klammer fehlt?
Nee.
Was, die Klammer fehlt?
Die Klammer fehlt?
Warum ist die Klammer denn weg?
WTF?
Warum?
Warum ist die Klammer weg?
Wo ist sie hin?
Hier geht es mir doch.
Okay, da können wir es jetzt nochmal machen.
Geil, toll.
Da war das gar nicht so schlecht.
Okay, aber ich probiere das jetzt mal mit dem Image aus,
was ich vorhabe.
Ich kann jetzt hier quasi sagen, Image.
So, das Standard-Image kriegt diesen Style.
Genau, dann kann ich das hier nämlich schon mal wegnehmen.
Das müsste immer noch funktionieren.
Du kannst dir der Browser-Konsole vertrauen.
Nee.
Kann ich nicht.
Weil, es könnte doch sein, nachdem ein Skript direkt hier drunter ist,
und wenn ich hier irgendwas kaputt gemacht habe, was syntaktisch nicht richtig ist,
dass das hier dann jetzt gar nicht ausgeführt wird.
Nachdem ich das hier alles inline habe und nicht einzeln auf mehrere Files verteilt,
was ich jetzt übrigens aber dank dem Pull-Request von Auskenn-Fuchs problemlos machen könnte,
ich könnte es jetzt alles aufteilen in HTML und CSS-Files und JavaScript-Files,
weil wir können jetzt ja einfach alle Ressourcen raushauen,
ohne dass wir da irgendwie Entpack-Action machen müssen.
Eats live ist das.
So, und dann machen wir jetzt noch ein Image-TTS.
Das kriegt eigentlich zusätzlich bloß als Border-Color kriegt das Purple.
Border-Color kriegt das Purple.
So, und dann haben wir noch Active.
Active is green.
So, und dann passt das, glaube ich.
Warum musst du immer starten stoppen, wenn du etwas bearbeitest?
Sind doch nur HTML, CSS, etc.
Nein, doch.
Also ich habe das hier embedded drin und das ist nicht so optimal, ja.
Ich will halt, dass ich eine Anwendung ausliefern kann, wo alles drin ist.
Deswegen ist das hier alles eingebaut und da surft das halt immer nur aus seinen Ressourcen.
Das ist aber doof, das müsste ich ein bisschen schöner machen.
Ich könnte ja einfach checken, ob ich quasi im Debug-Mode bin.
Dann surft er die aus einem Directory, in dem ich editieren kann.
Und ja, das machen wir, glaube ich, auch mal.
Ja, das ist doch viel besser.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich im Debug-Mode bin.
Das hätte ich gleich machen sollen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ich gucke, ob ich im Debug-Mode bin.
Wenn ich im Debug-Mode bin, dann surfen wir einfach hier ein Directory.
Und wenn ich im, ja, nicht im Debug-Mode bin, dann surfen wir quasi das.
Also dann geben wir einen Browser raus, das embeddet.
Ja, das ist eigentlich viel besser.
Das können wir gleich machen.
Einmal kurz gucken, ob mein CSS-Gedöns funktioniert, was ich jetzt gebastelt habe.
Also sprich, anstatt hier unten irgendwelche Inline-Styles zu setzen, könnte ich jetzt ja auch einfach sagen...
Wie sage ich das eigentlich?
Class, ne?
Class.
Classlist.
Add.
Und dann sage ich, ähm, active.
Das heißt, ich haue jetzt hier eine CSS-Class dran.
Active.
So, und hier unten haue ich eine CSS-Class dran, die sagt Text-to-Speech.
Boah, ob das klappt?
Bin ja mal gespannt.
Funktioniert?
Es funktioniert?
Nice.
So, dann können wir jetzt noch die...
Warte mal, wir machen das mit dem Web-Interface.
Wie kann ich eigentlich checken?
Check if debug.
Na, so will ich das nicht machen. Kann man nicht irgendwie abfragen?
If debug? Geht das nicht irgendwie?
Was läuft denn hier?
Das Meme-Tool läuft hier.
Beziehungsweise Feinschliff.
Ah ja, System-Ding, Debugger ist attached.
Das brauche ich, genau.
Und im Hintergrund läuft der Soundtrack von Ori.
So, also das heißt, von der Idee her könnte man doch jetzt hier eigentlich gucken.
If...
Rück nicht komisches Zeug für mich ein, Visual Studio, wenn ich das nicht will.
So, if debugger ist attached, dann machen wir das, was ich jetzt gleich dahinschreibe.
Else machen wir das.
So.
Wenn der Debugger attached ist, dann surfen wir...
Dann surfen wir... Nee, Path, muss man sagen.
Path.
Das ist doch Directory.
Genau, so.
Und dann ist ja auch...
...Physical File Provider.
Und dann wollen wir allerdings nicht...
...nicht das hier haben, sondern...
mal kurz gucken ob das funktioniert
also jetzt ist der Debugger Attached
starten wir den Cremple
ok das funktioniert
das heißt
ich kann das jetzt hier editieren
wenn ich das jetzt hier editiere
also sagen wir mal
wenn ich das jetzt hier editiere mal was offensichtliches
ich schreibe hier rein
hallo
oh nee
ich hab zu viele Memes gemapped
das kann ich nicht mehr speichern
wenn ich das jetzt speichere
ok das funktioniert sehr nice
das ist gut
dann kann ich das nämlich da drin editieren
sehr nice
ich muss jetzt nochmal die Memes unmappen
das geht ja auch live mittlerweile
zwar Steuerung S muss ich unmappen
ach fuck es ist geladen
ok ich mach nochmal aus
das kann ich ja nämlich direkt drin editieren und ausprobieren da geht das
viel besser
es gab doch auch irgendwo so eine
es gab doch auch irgendwo so ein Browser Plugin
wo man den Browser automatisch reloaden lassen konnte wenn sich
ein File ändert
kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
ich hab irgendwann verwendet
das wäre oder das
ich hab das gelöscht
ach nee der kopiert das ja immer
piss dich
komm
scheiß drauf wir machen das jetzt nachdem es ja immer zum entwickeln ist
wir sagen jetzt einfach hier zack
das Verzeichnis
mit der index HTML
da müssen wir gar kein Geschiss mehr machen
geht ja einfach nur dass wir schneller sind
kenne das nur von Angular nee ich hab irgendeinen Browser Plugin mal gesehen da ging das
start
ok
den hässlichen Rahmen müssen wir jetzt noch weg machen dann probieren wir das jetzt mit CSS Variable aus
jetzt können wir auch direkt
hier drin editieren
wenn ich jetzt hier
probieren wir mal aus ob das funktioniert
blablabla
ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung
ich hab wieder diese scheiß Dinger gemapped
ok das klappt
ok
gut
also Dark Mode haben wir am Start
mit so einem hässlichen Button hier oben
das sind hier Ctrl S
weg
piss dich
start
ok
was wollten wir denn jetzt schönes machen
genau ich wollte dieses CSS-Gedöns noch mal ausprobieren mit dem CSS-Variablen
also wie ging das nochmal minus minus Dark
und dann konnte man sagen
meinst du was wie LiveJS ja kann schon sein
die Rahmen entfernen ja genau die Rahmen will ich entfernen
und das hier ich will ja nicht überall neu schreiben
also
DarkBG
das war jetzt
lull
Steuerung C
bei DarkBG Anzeige ist raus
so
VQ Chat VQ
ok Steuerung C geht nicht das muss ich löschen
Steuerung C brauch ich zu oft
wo ist es denn da
no man brah
ok
so Dark
und dann sagen wir Dark hier DarkBG
LightBG
LightBG ist
oh guck mal die haben mittlerweile sogar einen Colour Picker drin
also man muss echt sagen ich meine das geht mit allen anderen Etidoren auch ja
aber man muss echt sagen Microsoft hat sich da schon Gedanken bei gemacht
ok an sich funktioniert es jetzt noch wir haben es ja noch nirgendswo eingesetzt
und jetzt musste man was sagen
war
und dann DarkBG
und dann hier
hab ich doch nie verwendet
LightBG
funktioniert immer noch
sehr schön sehr sehr nice
ok
genau jetzt machen wir die Rahmen hier weg
eigentlich haben wir gar keine Rahmen kann man das sagen
kann man irgendwie sagen gar keine Rahmen gucken wie es dann aussieht
ich meine
ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht genau warum das
ich weiß zwar nicht genau warum das so ist aber ich finde das ist ein guter Effekt
schwarz weiß schwarz weiß
weil eigentlich wollen wir die die die Rahmen ja immer die gleiche Farbe haben
also sprich
das heißt wir würden das jetzt wie machen
semantisch könnte ich würde das BG weglassen
naja nicht unbedingt
weil es könnte doch auch sein
dass ich quasi dass das der dunkle BG ist
und ich könnte ja auch sowas hier machen
wenn das für den dunklen BG ist
und das ist dann quasi für den dunklen
falls es eine andere Farbe wäre
so hast du natürlich recht
so weil jetzt ist ja im Prinzip beim dark mode die color quasi light
sony ist dark
der ori soundtrack ist gar nicht von ks jetzt
ok wie bringe ich denn jetzt meinen meinem image bei
wie bringe ich denn meinem image bei dass der ramen
beim dark theme
dunkel sein soll
machen das jetzt
ich meine klar ich könnte ich könnte sagen standardmäßig könnte ich sagen ist es so
ja stimmt leko stimmt
standardmäßig kann ich jetzt irgendwie sowas sagen aber
dann zwitsch das ganze ja nichts
warum soll ich warum soll ich den border null pixel machen
ach ich nupe
aber jetzt stimmts natürlich beim weit
beim weit nicht
warum soll ich denn den border auf null mal ich will doch den border haben
ich will doch den border
ich will den border haben wenn wenn es aktiv ist
ich will den border haben wenn es aktiv ist
wenn es aktiv ist border
ansonsten will ich halt wenn es inaktiv ist will ich halt nicht dass man das sieht
das heißt wie bringe ich denn jetzt dem
ok wahrscheinlich muss ich einfach hier drinne sagen ok
hier drinne muss ich jetzt wahrscheinlich die
wir gucken einfach mal in das code pen rein da hat er das doch vorhin auch gemacht
ach so guck mal hier body light mode button also sagt ich sage jetzt body light mode
body dark mode image sage ich dann
also ok also ich body light aber die autovervollständigung
vervollständigung ist schon cool
body light mode image das betrifft alle images da unten drunter
wobei das hier eigentlich body dark dark mode ist dark mode ist so dann haben wir
noch body light mode image ist light
und du schreckt oh nee warum überschreibt er das jetzt nicht mehr
warum überschreibt er das nicht mehr
warum warum überschreibt er das jetzt nicht mehr ich will wenn es aktiv ist
dass es überschrieben wird doch nicht jetzt als fuck
ich will dass es überschrieben wird das hat vorher wunderbar funktioniert
warum funktioniert das jetzt nicht
das muss jetzt irgendwie einer an das aktiv hat eine geringere
ach muss ich dann ausrufezeichen dahinter machen irgendwie so
das geht doch irgendwie da kann man doch überschreiben
Leute ich weiß das doch ihr müsst mir das gar nicht jetzt habe ich schon alles
vor das war mir echt gerade schöne
ich habe es auch noch falsch gemacht
ich habe es auch noch falsch gemacht es ist ja erstmal hier wichtig tun dass ich
das doch weiß und dann noch falsch gemacht
also body light mode image aktiv ach so ja aber ich will doch das für beides
gilt dahinter
ja wie mache ich das jetzt richtig ich weiß nicht
eigentlich muss ich den mal neu starten ich weiß auch nicht warum das darum
funktioniert
allerdings würde ich das schon gerne richtig machen also also der auskern
folks hat geschrieben man macht das nie der lego art hat geschrieben also body
light mode image aktiv kann man nicht so was machen wie nur mal so ich weiß nicht
kann ich nicht so was sagen body egal welcher mode
also wie auch immer da die richtige sonntags ist aber gibt sowas
nein
css wildcard
body image aktiv ok das probiere ich mal aus
bei sternchen sprichst du alles an ich will nicht alles ansprechen ich will
einfach alle images unterhalb von body also alle images ansprechen
ob body jetzt light oder dark ist weil das hier zählt wohl vor dem hier
ich weiß halt nicht so genau warum ehrlich gesagt
ok das heißt jetzt kann ich das important weg machen
irgendwie kackt das ding ab wenn ich das ändere dass das das index weiß ich so
genau warum ehrlich gesagt
funktioniert nice ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht genau warum
aber es funktioniert sehr sehr schön nice nice so nice so jetzt haben wir hier
oben ganz viel css gewurstet nachdem wir das immer abkackt schweiß ich das hier
wieder raus die bagge attached aufgeschissen
wow eine donation das scheiß ich guck nach moment
das ist baro wieder auf wuppler tv beziehungsweise max fps punkt tv gibt es
jetzt auch die streams von september 2017 marschiv habt ihr gestern eingenommen
sehr leise baro also für alle die meine streams sich angucken wollen noch mal
oder irgendwie was nachgucken wollen und es nicht mehr in den twitch wots drinne
ist könnt ihr mit max fps punkt tv beziehungsweise wuppler punkt tv direkt
ins archiv was da sie baro angelegt hat
image body sollte auch gehen wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich geht das
auch aber solange das auch so geht bin ich auch damit zufrieden das ist ok so ok
nice jetzt orten wir vielleicht noch unseren unseren button unten drunter an
weil ich mein das sieht schon ein bisschen kacke aus mit dem button da oben drauf
so mit dem button unten drunter ist doch viel besser kommen sogar ein dark
sie ist das nicht geil aber sogar noch ein dark sieben
lul wot omega lul omega lul so nice bei max was machst du beruflich das habe ich
schon öfters mir schwer getan das im stream zu umschreiben deswegen müsste
ich mir das eigentlich mal aufschreiben ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um genau
so wie es dabei dass ihr baro schreibt ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um unsere
sourcecode repos und um das erstellen neuer versionen von unserer software
beschreiben wir das mal so das merckte neue features um schon bestehende
releases mit hotfixes zu versorgen dann gucken dass wir einmal im monat auch ein
neues release zustande kriegen auch manchmal merck konflikte lösen und lange
dabei rumdiskutieren also quasi wie es ja sie baro geschrieben hat der chief
headmaster of get repository so wellens so weilens genau ich bin damit jetzt
eigentlich relativ zufrieden es ist zwar jetzt nicht super schick wisst ihr was
ein richtig geiler effekt wäre wenn man das jeweils aber da müssen wir mal
gucken dass das krieg ich soll es nicht gebacken wenn man das jeweils ausgewählte
dann quasi im hintergrund im hintergrund quasi halbtransparent zu sehen würde
irgendwie das war irgendwann anders was hältst du was hältst du von bambu man
muss mal überlegen bambu ist ist diese atlasien continuous integration
geschwuppeln wer merkt montags der azubi keiner montags merkt keiner ich habe
noch ich habe noch jemand der mich dabei unterstützt das heißt es wäre
theoretisch montag einer da aber normalerweise wird montags nicht gemärcht
montags ist mörch freier tag bei uns bin ich nicht da nicht gemärcht ist also
kann man nichts machen
montags können die leute ordentlich programmieren und dienstags kann ich
dann merken weil und so blöd ist jetzt also das ist gar nicht gefällt mir jetzt
gerade ein so blöd ist das gar nicht dass montags nicht gemärcht wird weil das
ist dann ein tag wo die leute motiviert sind und was machen und oftmals ist es
so dass das haben wir ganz oft dass quasi der entwickler quasi sagt er ist
fertig und reicht reicht das dann quasi für das nächste release als mörsch
requester pull request wie es bei github heißt ein und allerdings im laufe des
nächsten halben tages so bis tages fällt ihm dann halt trotzdem auf da fehlt
noch was das das das kommt ziemlich oft vor deswegen ist das eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht dass man mörch freien tag in der woche hat dass die leute wenn sie
montags super motiviert sind schon vielleicht dass die dann auch mal zeit
haben sich das anzugucken bis dienstag nachmittags so bis ich dann anfangen mit
dem kram das ist eigentlich so im nachhinein betrachtet jetzt ist es gar
nicht so schlecht zu sagen ein tag die woche wird nichts gemärcht
so haben wir noch irgendwas also wir haben jetzt ein schönes schönes web
freundin wir müssen das ganze müssen wir noch pushen ja das muss man auch
machen pushen das ganze klein noch haben wir noch irgendwas schönes
schönes ich meine das play symbol sieht nicht so nicht so toll aus aber das
ist ja eh so ein geripptes eiken
ich bin damit jetzt eigentlich relativ zufrieden für das dass ich eigentlich
keine ahnung von javascript und css und gedöns habe es ist deutlich hübscher
als vorher es ist immer noch genauso schnell außer wenn das ihr habt gerade
gesehen wenn das erste mal ein bild lädt dann ist es ist es lahm aber dann muss
das bild auch erst mal einlesen danach ist es schnell wenn es einmal geladen
hat das ist kein eiken serious max das shortcut kannst du weglassen
ja ja mal gucken das schnee
das ist kein eiken das ist nun das ist ein bild
warum dauert es eigentlich so lange die wupplos tv seite zu laden wahrscheinlich
weil das der sebar auf innen free hosting sonst was laufen hat aber die
videos sind schnell dafür und der traffic wahrscheinlich billig aber kann
kann man kann man echt bilder in wörten echt jetzt ok das probieren wir jetzt
mal aus ja klar was weiß ich wo soll das ist keine ahnung dass das geht es ist
da ist das ja gut ja ihr wisst das ja alle dann ist ja gut dann machen wir das
also es heißt wie machen wir das jetzt genau
so ok da müssen wir das doch moment wartet mal kurz
wie mache ich das jetzt gescheit
weil ich will ja nur ich will ja nur das hier na gut da braucht es eine extra
klasse irgendwie oder wobei nie oder doch nie klasse tts so ok probieren ob das
theoretisch funktioniert
ok wie soll das ganze jetzt gehen moment ok ok ok also heißt jetzt wenn soll also
es heißt filter filter in wort ok das ist wahrscheinlich weil das bei webkit
mal wieder anders warum warum heißt es bei webkit anders bei apple
warum ist es bei apple wieder anders also sagen wir filter in wort machen wir jetzt
mal das sollte soll das halt standardmäßig dann da in wortet sich
nichts
ach nee das ist ja nur wenn es aktiv ist funktioniert
allerdings will ich ja nur das image in wort ich will nur das image in wort nicht
den rahmen drumherum das ist dann doch nicht so einfach oder was kann man machen
wenn man seinen monitor durchs draufhauen zerstört hat ich würde sagen
neuen monitor kaufen da wird es nicht so viele möglichkeiten geben also wenn die
scheibe kaputt ist es kaputt halt und bei einem lcd ist halt auch nicht nur
scheibe kaputt da ist dann halt auch kristalle kaputt und zeugs kaputt da
kannst du ja wahrscheinlich nur neu kaufen ori hat echt einen nice soundtrack ein nicer soundtrack ist das
kannst du nicht auf dein rgb von image class zugreifen bestimmt irgendwie aber
das ist mir eigentlich zu welcher rahmen der hier
der rahmen wird in wortet
vom image ach so meinst du das du meinst dass man quasi sagt also dass man quasi
sowas machen würde wie was ist denn hier dass man quasi nicht nur dass man hier
noch eine andere klasse dazu macht also irgendwie sowas dass ich plupp und dann
sagt man quasi ich war gespannt ob das klappt dann sagt man quasi hier in wort
eins plupp oder mal gucken ob das funktioniert egal
egal funktioniert nicht macht nichts da muss ich was anderes ausdenken
aber das ist schon mal ganz nice so wie es jetzt ist ich lösche den krempel jetzt
mal wieder ne ich brauche border color ersten springen die bilder sonst doof
rum und ich will es ja markieren mit ich will ja ich will ja den rahmen drumherum
machen wenn es aktiv ist also ich brauche den border wenn es aktiv ist
wenn es aktiv ist soll es grün sein die border kann er mit invertieren ja das ist
doof quasi verkehrt mitgeben damit sie richtig vergehen das würde wahrscheinlich
funktionieren ja ich kann dir diesen mix empfehlen zum programmieren aha das
können wir uns jetzt gleich mal an ori soundtrack ist eh fertig okay ach das ist
ein das kenne ich das ist die haben noch viel mehr sachen remix das ist nice ja
das stimmt aber man muss halt sagen dass majora's mask soundtrack halt ziemlich
monka es ist das finde ich nicht entspannend er ist eher schon ein
bisschen gruselig höre ich das mal an so übelst soundtrack
so das lassen wir jetzt erstmals mit dem border so ich meine ich bin hier ich
wie gesagt ich bin über dieses java script geschwuppelt hier eher so ganz
glücklich drinnen das ist voll monka es das soundtrack gibt das oh das ist
wer man
Ja, Tommy, das hatte ich gerade so. Das hat doch nicht funktioniert.
Ich hatte eben eine extra Klasse für das Invert.
Das war einfach mir nicht geschachtel- Ach so!
Boah, nee.
Das wird mir zu kompliz- Ich muss schnell mal ein bisschen- Ich muss mir eh mal ein bisschen Gedanken machen.
Vielleicht machen wir das Ganze auch mit irgendeinem krassen, trendigen JavaScript-Framework.
Da muss man den ganzen Krempel nicht von Hand machen.
Zumindest nicht so extrem von Hand machen.
Ich muss halt dazu sagen, ich habe außer dem Vue.js-Tutorial habe ich mir da noch nicht allzu viel angeguckt.
Das ist ja auch nicht so kompliziert, was wir machen.
Aber es ist doch gar nicht so übel. Ich finde das schon ganz nice.
Was muss ich hier mal P5.js angucken?
Was ist P5.js?
JavaScript-Frameworks gibt es ja quasi.
Ach so, das ist irgendeine Grafikgeschichte. Okay.
Guck mal, das ist so kaputt, dass man nicht mal scrollen kann, die Seite.
So viel zum Thema JavaScript, ne?
Null.
Also wahrscheinlich blocke ich hier irgendwas drauf.
Nö.
Ich kann nicht mal scrollen auf der Seite.
Oder gibt es hier gar nichts? Man kann nix scrollen und nix markieren.
Ich hasse solche Sachen.
Ich hasse solche JavaScript-Seiten, die meinen Browser kaputt machen, ey.
Guck mal, kann ich es noch mal anklicken?
Oh, das benutze ich nicht.
So, gut.
Gibt es jetzt noch irgendwas, was wir machen wollten heute?
Ich pushe das gleich, wenn wir hier fertig sind noch.
Ist der Text eine Grafik?
Welcher Text?
Ach so, der Text ist da drauf. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Wobei ich mich halt frage, ne, ist es nicht?
Was weiß ich mal?
Es ist JavaScript bis zum Umfallen, ey.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Keine Ahnung, das ist mir zu viel JavaScript-Geskripte auf der Seite.
Ja, ich würde sagen, an der Stelle haben wir hier noch etwas.
Ja, ich würde sagen, an der Stelle haben wir das nächste Mal weiter.
Ich uploade das Ganze jetzt auch.
Wir brauchen auch noch unbedingt eine Stimmen-Auswahl für Text-to-Speech.
Weil aktuell kann das ja nur Microsoft George ist es, glaube ich.
Warte mal, Leute, wir gucken noch mal kurz, was es für Stimmen zur Auswahl gibt.
Also, wir haben zur Auswahl...
Ich muss mal kurz auf Konsole umstellen, da ich was sehe.
Also, wir haben zur Auswahl an Stimmen...
Wir testen mal, was es da für Stimmen gibt.
Haben wir hier irgendwo zwischendrin.
Also, wir haben Voice, irgendwas mit Voice.
Installed Voices.
Voice-Info-Name.
So, lassen wir uns das mal ausgehen, was es für Voice-Voices gibt.
Also, wir haben David, Hazel und Zira.
Dann lassen wir die doch mal labern.
Wollen wir mal Test-Text-to-Speech mit allen Stimmen gucken.
Wobei, man kann sich das... kann man sich das hier nicht.
Das kann man sich hier doch...
Nee, man kann sich das auch hier.
Also, das ist David.
Den... den... den kennen wir schon.
Haben wir Hazel.
Nein.
Und dann haben wir Zira.
Dann noch...
Also, die anderen habe ich wohl nicht installiert.
Keine Ahnung, die habe ich zumindest nicht zur Auswahl.
Da ist... da ist David noch am besten, oder?
Da ist David noch am besten.
Der Rest ist ja ganz grausam.
Wie kann man zusätzliche Schriften eigentlich installieren?
Äh, nicht Schriften.
Zusätzliche Voices.
Install... Voice.
Für die ganzen Weeps unter uns.
Get more Microsoft Texts.
Ja, okay, wie kann man jetzt...
Das ist auch wieder so super kompliziert bei Microsoft alles.
Warum kann man hier nicht einfach...
eine neue... eine neue Sprache hinzufügen?
You can download some Voices from Free TTS.
Was?
Free Texts to Speech.
Von der Seite lade ich mir nichts runter.
Das sieht schon...
Nee.
Nee, ich will keine Web...
Ich will keine Web API verwenden für Texts to Speech.
Da müsste man den Gramstel jedes Mal quasi online schicken
und dann wieder...
wieder empfangen und dann abspielen.
Das wird auch viel zu... wahrscheinlich viel zu viel laggen quasi.
Da brauchst du ja dann immer eine halbe Sekunde bis es losgeht.
Windows 10 Voice Weep.
Wir brauchen eine... eine Weep Stimme.
TTS.
Ah, das hängt davon ab.
Was für eine Sprache man ist hier.
Ah, gut.
Natürlich, ich hab's...
Ich hab's ja nur...
Ich krieg wahrscheinlich nur die Sprachen angezeigt für Englisch jetzt.
Ich hab hier...
Ich hab David.
David.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Cute Texts to Speech Guide.
Keine Ahnung.
Das müsst ihr dem Ding aber noch beibringen.
Das lässt das Tool durch die Decke gehen,
wenn das Anime Weep Voice drin hat zum Vorlesen.
Das muss ja streamtauglich sein, weil ich mein...
Das ist langweilig, ne?
Ich mein, Microsoft David ist langweilig.
Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall noch zwei weitere Stimmen.
Wir brauchen einmal so eine...
Eine ultra männliche Stimme, die das Ganze vorliest.
Brauchen wir einmal noch.
Und dann brauchen wir noch...
Dann brauchen wir noch irgendeine Weep Stimme.
Und dann brauchen wir noch irgendwie so eine...
So eine Kraygasm Stimme.
So was irgendwie.
Oh, Megalol.
Das ist so was in der Richtung, brauchen wir noch.
Das kommt immer gut an, soll ich dir sagen.
Ja.
Ich muss noch ein paar Texts to Speech Sachen raussuchen
und wahrscheinlich müssen wir dann auch
irgendeine andere Texts to Speech Library verwenden,
anstatt die...
Was?
Probier mal.
Hapu Software.
Was soll immer?
Was soll eine Weep Stimme sein?
Moment.
Wer hat...
Wer hat ein gutes Beispiel für eine super...
Super Beispiel Stimme?
Okay, Hapu Software.
Muss das Text to Speech sein?
Ja klar muss das Text to Speech sein,
weil ich will ja...
Ich will ja hier ein Textfile hinlegen,
wo ich den Text reinschreibe, den er vorlesen soll.
Also ich will da reinschreiben können, was ich will.
Find your voice, language.
Japanese.
Brand.
Egal.
Female.
Moment, ich will das nicht kaufen.
Ich will das nicht kaufen.
Cute Texts to Speech Guide.
Das brauchen wir.
Das sind Sachen, die will ich hier nicht on stream aufmachen.
Ich weiß nicht, was da passiert, wenn ich da drauf gehe.
Das muss man einbauen unbedingt.
Das schauen wir dann schlecht.
Ich muss mal gucken, was es für Texts to Speech Sachen gibt.
Okay.
Das muss ich mal in einem Offstream gucken.
Ich traue mich hier nicht, on stream die ganzen Seiten aufzumachen.
Was gibt es denn so für...
Mary.
Ja, muss ich mal auf stream gucken, was da so alles gibt.
Ja klar.
Klar.
30 Meter Kabel ist überhaupt kein Ding.
30 Meter Kabel brauchst du nicht mal gute Kabel für Gigabit.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich die letzte Kröte verlegen über 30 Meter.
Nee, es können keine Soundfiles sein, weil ich will da reinschreiben, was er vorliest.
Okay Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Da merkt man, dass es ein Zeller Soundtrack ist.
Also ein Remix.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Ich gucke mal aufs Team, was es da so für Voice Geschichten noch gibt.
Was ist Hex War?
Was war dir klar?
Hex Fort CSGO.
Natürlich dann.
Bester Name wieder.
Streamst du heute noch?
Ich strebe gerade.
Nee, heute nicht mehr.
Du kommst ins Stream, es ist vorbei.
Ja, ich muss ja auch mal irgendwann was essen.
Ich gucke mal aufs Team, was es da so für Textos Speech Geschichten noch gibt.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Ich push das Ganze jetzt gleich noch.
Macht es gut.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.